This is Jocko podcast number one 19 with Echo Charles and me,
Jocko Willink.
Good Evening Echo.
Good evening
on September 11th 400 miles from the collapse of World Trade Center towers,
three dozen passengers and crew aboard United Flight 93 remained in airborne
purgatory.
Yeah.
Starting at 9:30 AM for some 30 minutes.
14 of them manage to telephone,
either loved ones or operators on the ground.
Public Relations Man,
Mark Bingham got through to his aunt's home in California.
Okay.
This is mark.
He began,
I want to let you guys know that I love you in case I don't see you again.
Okay.
Then I'm on United Airlines flight 93 it's being hijacked.
Two other callers from the plane,
not only provided information,
but also gleaned vital news from those.
They phoned Tom Burnett,
chief operating officer for a medical devices from,
made her number of brief calls to his wife Dina.
Okay.
Speaking quietly.
He asked her to contact the authorities and told her that a male passenger had
been stabbed.
Later that he had died,
a woman,
perhaps a flight attendant was being held at knife point and the hijackers
claimed they had a bomb.
Okay.
Jeremy Glick.
Yeah.
A salesman for an Internet services company also managed to phone in a long
conversation with his wife,
Liz Glick said the hijackers had put on these red headbands.
They said they had a bomb.
They looked Iranian.
Okay.
The bomb was in a red box.
He said,
okay.
The couple told each other how much they loved each other.
Okay.
Glick said,
I don't want to die,
and his wife are assured him that he would not.
She urged him to keep a picture of her and they're 11 week old daughter in his
head.
To think good thoughts.
Burnett's wife who had been watching the news on television told him that two
planes had crashed into the world trade center.
My God,
he responded,
it's a suicide mission.
By the time he phoned a third time after news of the crashed into the Pentagon,
she told them about that too.
Yeah.
Burnett seems to have been seated beside Glick and apparently relayed all this
information to him.
Were they to do nothing?
The two men must've agreed they were sure to die anyway.
When the hijackers crashed the plane,
they resolved to fight for their lives.
Yeah.
A group of US Burnett told his wife are getting ready to do something.
I'm going to take a vote,
click set on his call.
There's three other guys as big as me and we're thinking of attacking the guy
with the bomb.
So began the minutes of brave resistance.
The clearly defined act of courage that has lived on in the national memory.
Glick and others were equipped in more ways than one to confront the hijackers.
Glick was six foot one and a former college judo champion Burnett at six foot
two had played quarterback for his high school football team.
Mark Bingham was a huge man,
six foot four and at 31 still playing rugby a few years earlier.
He had fended off a mugger who had a gun.
His mother got the impression as he talked from flight 93 that our son was
talking confidently with a fellow passenger.
Okay.
She felt that maybe someone had organized a plan.
At nine 42 a GTE version supervisor based near Chicago began handling a call
from yet another powerfully built flight.
93 passenger.
Okay.
Todd beamer,
a star Oracle software salesman was married with two sons and his wife was
expecting again.
Yeah.
He first dialed his home number,
but either failed to get through or thought better of it.
Instead explaining it it he'd not want to upset his pregnant wife.
He asked the phone supervisor lead Lisa Jefferson to pass along a loving message
as they talked,
beamer suddenly exclaimed shit.
Oh my God,
we're going down.
Jesus help us.
Okay.
From the passengers around beamer came prolonged shrieks of terror.
Then he said,
no,
wait,
we're coming back up.
I think we're okay now.
Okay.
Shakin beamer ass Jefferson to say the Lord's prayer with him.
Our Father who art in heaven
just before beamer and the operator had begun talking.
Cleveland last Cleveland Control last flight,
93 is transponder.
The signal that indicates an airplane's location and altitude.
That nine 55 the hijacker pilots set a navigational aid relating to the plains
direction he was heading.
It indicated
okay
for Washington DC.
Jeremy Glick still on the phone to his wife.
Liz said,
I,
I could take this guy with the bomb.
Yeah.
Then joking.
He had mentioned that the hijackers had knives.
I still have my butter knife from breakfast.
Okay.
Todd beamer,
continuing in his conversation with the GTE supervisor,
Jefferson told her that he and a few others were getting together to jump the
guy with the bomb.
Okay.
Was He sure that that was what he wanted to do?
Yes.
Came the response,
I'm going to have to go out on faith.
Okay.
I don't have much of a choice.
The plane was flying a radically again.
Okay.
Operator Jefferson heard the sounds of an awful commotion,
raised voices,
more screams.
Then are you guys ready?
And Todd beamers voice saying,
let's roll
a phrase that in family life he'd like to use to get his children moving.
Okay.
Jeremy Click cold.
Told his wife,
Liz,
I'm going to do it.
Okay.
His wife told him he was strong and brave and that she loved him.
He said again,
I'm going to put the phone down.
I'm going to leave it here and I'm going to come right back to it.
Liz handed the phone to her father ran to the bathroom and gagged
flight attendant.
Sandra Bradshaw was in the Galley boiling water for the passengers to throw on
the hijackers on the phone to her husband.
She signed off quickly.
Everyone's running up to first class.
I've got to go.
Bye.
The cockpit voice recorder registered.
The moment the hijackers realized what was happening at just before nine 58 a
hijacker asks,
is there something,
a fight.
There's a knock on the door followed by the sounds of fighting.
Then an Arabic.
Let's go guys.
Allah is the greatest allies.
Greatest.
Oh guys,
a law greatest.
Oh La la La la.
Oh,
the most gracious.
Yeah.
Then loudly stay back.
A male voice and native English speaking voice that Tom Burnett's wife has
recognized is that of her husband is heard saying in the cockpit,
in the cockpit,
followed by voice exclaiming an Arabic.
They want to get in here.
Hold,
hold from the inside hold.
Yeah.
Then from several English speakers in uniform,
unison hold the door and then from a single English speaker stopped him,
followed repeatedly by sit down,
sit down.
Then again from an English speaker,
let's get them
flight 93 now to 5,000 feet had begun rolling left and right.
Jeremy Glicks father-in-law listening intently on the phone.
His daughter had handed to him.
Now heard screams in the background.
Yeah.
On the cockpit voice recorder.
There's the sound of combat continuing.
Then in Arabic there is nothing.
Shall we finish it off?
No,
not yet.
When they all come,
we finish it off.
Then from Tom Burnett,
I am injured.
The flight data recorder indicates that the plane pitched up and down climbed at
10,000 feet turned.
Yeah.
Glicks father in law foam clap too.
Is your heard more shrieks muffled now?
Like those of people riding on a roller coaster.
Okay.
In Arabic on the voice recorder.
Oh,
ah,
oh gracious.
In English.
In the cockpit.
If we don't,
we'll die
in Arabic,
up,
down,
down from a distance,
perhaps from Todd beamer roll it
crashing sounds then in Arabic,
uh,
law as the greatest law as the greatest.
Is that it?
I mean,
shall we put it down?
Yes.
Put it in and pull it down.
Cut off the oxygen.
Up,
down,
up,
down.
More violent noises for as long as a minute.
And then apparently from a native English speaker,
shut them off.
Go,
go,
move,
move.
Turn it up.
Then an Arabic down,
down.
Pull it down.
Down.
Yeah.
Apparently from an English speaker down,
push,
push.
Okay.
In Arabic.
Hey,
hey,
give it to me.
Give it to me.
Intermittent loud air noise on the cockpit recorder.
Moments later in Arabic,
uh,
laws,
the greatest,
uh,
laws,
the greatest,
uh,
laws,
the greatest,
uh,
laws,
the greatest,
uh,
laws,
the greatest.
There's sounds of further struggle and the loud shout from a native English
speaker,
no
two seconds later in Arabic in a whisper now
allows the greatest,
uh,
laws,
the greatest,
uh,
laws,
the greatest,
uh,
laws,
the greatest.
Jeremy Glicks father-in-law still listening on the ground,
heard high pitched screams coming over the line.
Glick had left open when he left the join to join the rush to the cockpit.
Then when the sounds followed by banging noises as though the phone to board the
plane was repeatedly being banged on a hard surface.
After that
silence on the phone,
silence on the cockpit voice recorder.
And that is an excerpt.
Okay.
From a book called the 11th Day,
which came out in 2011 by
Anthony Summers and Robyn Swan.
Okay.
And we all know what that silence meant.
Yeah.
Flight 93 crashed into a field near the diamond t mind and Stony Creek Township,
Somerset County,
Pennsylvania,
killing 33 innocent passengers,
seven innocent crew members
and for demonic hijackers.
Yeah,
that day changed.
Okay.
My world,
and it changed our world.
The world as we knew it
turned it commenced to years and years.
Okay.
And years of war that has cost
so many lives.
And at some point on this podcast,
I'm sure we'll go into more details about the horrors of September 11th you
probably be multiple podcasts,
but for today,
I wanted to focus on one aspect of one part of the life of one man.
On that flight,
the man named Jeremy Glick,
who
by all accounts was an amazing human being,
a son and a husband and a father.
But for those of us
who fight or who trained martial arts and Gen general,
something caught our ears.
When we heard about the heroics on flight 93
we heard that Jeremy Glick was a martial artist,
that he was a wrestler and that he was a judoka.
And as a wrestler,
he wasn't competitive.
All state wrestler for Saddle River Day School in northern New Jersey.
If you know anything about New Jersey wrestling,
it's an extremely competitive wrestling state.
And beyond that,
as a judo player,
Glick was an American national collegiate judo champion.
While he was a student at the University of Rochester.
And in September of 2008
seven years after the incident,
September 11th there was a memorial ceremony
at the crash site in Pennsylvania and the United States Judo Association Place
Day granted stone there as a memorial with an inscription on it.
And the inscription reads,
the United States Judo Association promote promoted Jeremy Glick to the highest
rank of black belt for living the principle of judo.
Yeah.
Mutual welfare and benefit sacrificing his life for our country.
September 11th,
living the principle of judo.
And that's a bold statement.
It indicates something very powerful and very meaningful
and
as a patriot and as a martial artist and specifically as a Jujitsu practitioner,
which is where judo was derived from,
I wanted to explore a little deeper into the principles of judo to see what we
can learn from it.
And I don't want to go into the full details
of explaining the relationships between Jujitsu and judo,
but it is a very close relationship.
It was one of g goro pain owes top students and Kainos the creator of judo.
But my eda that brought Jujitsu to Brazil from Japan and introduced Jujitsu to
Carlos and Eylea Gracie,
and that's the beginning of Brazilian Jujitsu as we know it today.
And my unit even called it Jujitsu,
he didn't call it judo.
And from what I understand at that time,
even Kaino had not been actually calling it judo in Japan.
He hadn't renamed it yet.
He was still calling it Jujitsu and some people were calling it Kaino Jujitsu or
Kodachrome Jujitsu.
But Jujitsu,
especially Brazilian Jujitsu is without question rooted in judo.
And if you trace it back just a little bit further,
judo is also routed back into Jujitsu.
That's where judo came from.
Judo came from Jujitsu
in
mixed in with all that,
there's all kinds of evolution and there's changes and there's politics and
there's history,
but there's that thread that ties them all together and that thread can be
recognized in
many of the principles that are shared both in judo and in Jujitsu,
the same principles that played a role in Jeremy glicks attitude on that
clear,
sunny September day.
And perhaps we can all learn something from those principles.
And to look at those principles,
I thought it would be best to go to the source.
And I have a book called mind over muscle that is,
it's,
it's a compilation of writings from Igor okaynow and Kainoa was uh,
a very interesting person.
He was a,
he was an educator,
he was a pioneer in sports.
He worked with the Olympic Committee.
He was a Jujitsu practitioner,
eventually founded judo and he founded the most famous judo school,
the original judo school,
the Kodo con.
And the book,
like I said,
as,
as you can tell by the title,
it's a compilation of different sources of his writings.
And there's a little bit of overlap and repeat and I'll do a little bit of that.
But what I like about it is it gives a good overall view of the ideas and the
vision that Kaino had for Judah.
So I know there's a lot of judo practitioners out there and obviously a lot of
Jujitsu practitioners out there that listen to the podcast and everyone knows
that these two are closely related.
And sometimes there's a,
I guess you'd say tension between the two sometimes,
but the fact of the matter is there are so closely related that it's,
it'd be more,
it'd be more intelligent instead of look for the tension between the two to find
where the two can compliment each other.
So here we go into the book and once again the book is mind over muscle writings
from the founder of judo.
Did you go to Cato?
And here we go to start it off the purpose of Jujitsu.
So interesting that he starts this off.
It's talking about Jujitsu.
He's not even talking about judo yet.
The original purpose of Jujitsu was to practice a method of combat.
Well combat may have been at the core of Jujitsu practice.
It also had the related goals of physical education and mental training.
There was a little dispute that because training to fight involves moving the
body in various ways to get to indirectly became a form of physical education.
But for the same reason it also became a method for training the mind.
All Forms of combat require ingenuity and the use of various tricks and devices.
So all forms of combat,
all forms of combat.
This is important
because when you,
if you're,
if you're a soldier,
you're a marine or Europe airman,
right now we're talking about everything that you do.
And I'll tell you what,
if you're a business person,
we're talking about what you're doing to all forms of combat,
required ingenuity and the use of various tricks and devices.
So in the course of Jujitsu training,
the mind is unconsciously trained.
In many ways,
courage,
composer,
composure,
and other traits that are beneficial in life can also be developed.
Now,
I'll tell you what,
this is important because people ask me a lot like,
uh,
you know,
how'd you figure all this stuff out?
Jocko?
When people ask me that,
and you know,
I,
I always try to explain,
you know,
like it was a long course and I was in the military for a long time and I had an
open mind and I listened to paid attention to the people that were leading me
and I paid attention,
the good ones.
And I paid attention to the bad ones.
But I'll tell you if I didn't,
I jujitsu opened my mind up and did these things,
and again,
unconsciously,
like I started to perceive things the way that I was learning Jujitsu.
And that's why,
and I've got some,
I've got,
you know,
I've got friends that I've gotten into Jujitsu over the years and you can tell,
and I don't know what makes some people get the bug and some people don't get
the bug,
but if you get the bug and you start to think in a Jujitsu mindset,
then y'all,
it'll really open up your mind.
Now,
that being said,
there's some people that are heavily into Jujitsu,
but they don't apply Jiu Jitsu to the f the other aspects of their life,
which is a big mistake.
It's a big mistake.
You got to apply it both ways.
And I think that's one of the things that,
that Cato was trying to do with judo was to ensure that you did that,
to ensure that his students did that.
Hmm.
All right.
Back to the book,
it was my belief that with a few improvements,
Jujitsu could become a comprehensive method of physical education.
Intellectual training and moral education.
I therefore spent several years developing my ideas and finally established the
Kodokan judo.
I did this by thoroughly researching the Jujitsu that had existed up until the
time,
up until that time,
as much as possible,
keeping what I felt should be kept discarding what I felt should be discarded,
thoroughly studying the techniques and theories and establishing them in a way
that would be most applicable to today's society.
It's not even talking about just combat.
He's talking about like he's not talking about fighting,
he's like talking about applying these things to society.
So there's a little bit of,
I think he was young when he did this too.
He established the Kodokan at a very young age,
I want to say he was like 22 years old.
He was really young,
so he studied Jujitsu slots and things were good about it.
Thought some things were bad about it and said,
I'm gonna make my own deal.
Now here we talk a little bit here.
There were,
there were various reasons why I chose not to use the term Jujitsu,
which described what was ordinarily practiced and instead employee the name
judo.
The main reason was that dough,
the dough part of judo,
judo,
it means way
is the major force is a major focus of what the code econ teachers,
whereas Jitsu skill is incidental.
I also wanted to make it clear that judo was a means of embarking on the way,
so he saw this as like a complete a complete life system,
right?
Not just fighting.
This is the way judo is the way for him and that's why he,
instead of calling it Jujitsu,
he called it,
you know,
not,
not tick techniques but like the way
back to the book.
When we talk about Jujitsu today,
people often think of a technique in which one does only dangerous things such
as choking and opponent and bending his joints or even in extreme cases killing
him.
Essentially we think of something that is harmful to the whole,
to the body while offering no benefits to Jujitsu does not espouse this in
particular,
the Kodokan judo I devised never involves doing anything dangerous.
I cannot stress enough that what I advocate is far from a violent or dangerous
sport.
No,
sure.
I understand the principal there,
but just so everyone knows,
judo doesn't play around.
If you've,
if you've gone with a high level,
do judo player,
you are getting thrown hard and aggressively onto your head.
Yeah.
It's a brutal sport.
It's a,
it's very aggressive.
Do you think that that's how,
that's what,
because when it comes down to the essence,
it's kind of like in this just me totally guessing where judo,
well,
as it is now,
it's like,
okay.
The goal is basically to put the guy in his back.
That's it.
Put them down in the ground,
not to hit him,
not to knock them down,
put them on the ground.
Right.
Just kind of seems okay.
That's a really violent,
that's kind of the little friendly competition.
Put them on the ground.
Now with any competitive situation,
oh guys,
I'm going to get after it.
And it slowly just evolves into all these crazy things but doesn't evolve.
It escalates.
Escalates even just the whole way.
So even consider like basketball for example,
the goal,
put that ball in that basket.
That's it.
You can go from here,
come close lab,
whatever.
And then you,
you get this competitive drive,
these people,
athletic abilities,
all this stuff.
Now it's turning into weird slam dunks.
Now Brett,
you didn't have to slam dunk that thing,
but it's still the same thing.
Putting the ball in the thing just in this weird aggressive
I guess.
Yeah,
I guess,
yeah.
I guess a lay up compared to a Tomahawk slam dunk.
Right.
And if you compare a,
uh,
let's say some sort of a basic takedown compared to like a full,
if Paul and the slams in your head.
Yeah,
I could see your,
I can see your comparison.
See what I'm saying?
There's an escalation.
Yeah.
And then his mind,
he was like,
hey look at,
this is just a takedown.
You tell that to a 21 year old judo competitor.
That's got you in there just to take down.
Nope.
You're going to pay the band.
Yeah,
exactly right.
Just like you know,
a basket.
A basket.
Oh yeah.
He made that basket.
No,
but he slammed on you and you know,
embarrass you in front of it.
You know,
like he goes into this whole different realm.
But the essence is still there though.
Just the basket.
So breast just to take down.
Yup.
Alright.
Here we go.
Back to the book of the Organization of Kodokan.
Judo is basically the same today as it was when I established it.
But at that time when explaining judo,
I divided it into three parts.
It's use as a fighting method,
martial art as a training method,
physical education,
and as a method of mental training,
including the development of the intellect and more rules and the application of
the principles of judo to everyday life.
See,
this is again,
this is what's interesting to me is,
and he said it was subconscious.
Like I subconsciously,
especially in the beginning with Jujitsu I,
and I'll tell you,
it was beyond just me applying Jujitsu to like my life and to what I had learned
about combat.
I also took what I had learned about combat and applied that into Jujitsu.
Right?
Like I said,
Oh yeah,
you know what this is like when you flank someone,
right?
Yeah.
But even,
even when
I first learned,
one of the,
one of the biggest wakeup calls that you get early in Jujitsu is like,
oh,
what I need to do is attack your neck and when you defend your neck,
I take your arm.
Right.
That's a flank.
Right?
That's just a straight up flank.
That's,
that's a game changer.
Like that's a complete game changer when you realize that that's a complete game
changer.
Well the,
there's a seal buddy of mine that had been training when I first started out.
He'd been trained in for like a year.
No,
but he'd been trading off and on kind of bits and pieces.
And so then I started training hardcore like every day.
So after like two weeks,
like literally two weeks,
I went and trained with him and I,
and I got him like a bunch of times and I was all pumped up and,
and I said to him,
I was like,
hey,
you know what you,
the mistake that you're making is you're trying,
you're going from my arm and I know you're going from Ann Arbor and I'd know how
to defend that.
It was like you got to go for something else.
And then like a week later we rolled again and he got me did what I told them to
do to me and I was like,
Oh Dang.
So that was a big wake up call.
It's a big,
not even a waste.
It's a revelation when you realize,
oh you,
you've got to do,
you've got to set that.
You got to fight the person.
That's what you have to do.
Big wakeup call.
It's so crazy when you see two people were rolling in,
all they're doing is flanking each other.
Oh,
and your flanking the flooring,
Steve.
But what's interesting is as I started working with like leaders and teaching
about leadership,
how important the idea of what flanking is from a leadership and it and a human
interaction perspective.
On the other side you got a flank,
people you want to attack that ego and you know.
All right.
Back to the book,
two methods of instruction are used Kata,
which is form and Ren Dory,
which is free practice.
It's what we call him the Jujitsu rolling.
When establishing the Kodokan,
I employed a method that emphasized Randori and by which caught on naturally
came to be understood during Randori practice.
This is rather so he focused on rolling a lot.
When he established code pay attention.
This is very interesting.
Then Dory [inaudible] rolling.
It's rolling.
It's going to remember that
this is rather like teaching composition without using a grammar book or
teaching the basis of grammar while teaching how to write an essay,
so this is like,
hey man,
write this down and you got to make some corrections and like that's that's
basically rolling live,
right?
Yeah.
When there are only a few people undergoing the training.
This was not a problem,
but the number of beginners gradually increased and it became impossible to
teach caught at the same time as Randori.
So a few years after I established Kodokan judo,
I created 15 catia fur throws and 10 quarter for combat called Keema,
no Kata,
which meant forms of self defense.
So he realized he couldn't teach the same way he couldn't teach the masses.
So what,
you know,
that's,
that's a big change,
right?
There is a big,
big change for anyone that's not in the martial arts.
A big,
big difference between rolling and learning Catia.
And,
and matter of fact,
we make fun of Kata,
right?
I'm not saying that's a good thing.
Yeah.
But we w I,
I shouldn't say we completely make fun of it,
but like,
I'll see dean and let's say he's,
I can tell he's tired,
you know,
he's looking all worn out and I'll see you.
And I'm like,
Oh yeah.
Hey,
what's going on man?
You want to train some Catia today?
Meaning,
Hey,
are we just going to go through the motions and not actual drill?
You drink?
No,
no.
We're going to train,
right?
So that when I say make fun of it,
you don't make fun of it because,
because what we call caught a,
basically in Jujitsu we call it drilling,
right?
You're going to drill this drill,
drill drill,
which drilling is part of winning.
You've got to drill the win,
right?
Andre Galvao drillers to make killers,
drillers make killers.
There.
It was all those things.
That being said,
we all know if you do nothing but drill,
you're not going to be able to pull these moves off going live.
And this with the old tradition,
what we now call traditional martial arts,
that was all cotton and all Kata will get you nowhere.
That's when the guys,
when you saw that the 90s when the Jujitsu invasion happened,
you know the guy would try his 12 point strike Kata method against a blue belt
in Jujitsu.
The Blue Belt,
we'll do a sloppy Duggal double leg,
take them down to the ground and choke them out cause they rolled live.
They did Randori so you have to have balance,
but you got train,
live Randori and at the same time you got to drill too.
So be careful.
Don't do too much in one.
Seems like the drilling helps you get a hold of what you do with your buddy and
then the,
the brand dory,
the light,
the rolling.
Yeah.
Gives you,
uh,
you know,
control or,
or better skill in dealing with other people for sure.
And that's what Jesus is both,
you know,
and where you can kind of,
and you're going to get,
you're going to get
reactions that are different.
Right?
Right.
And this is the same thing.
This is the same thing.
Like when I was training guys in the teams,
like you could teach them the basics of how to enter a Roman and how to move
down a hallway.
But as soon as you put,
uh,
another person,
they're going against them.
There's like a different things happen.
Different things are going to happen and you gotta be ready for.
So you have to go live.
I tell,
I've told,
I told you this story before,
but when I first started playing basketball and my coach,
I had the old school,
you had the old school Hoosiers coach,
right?
You know the old school,
you've seen the movie Hoosiers?
No.
Oh Damn.
So in Hoosiers,
the guy's old school coach,
like,
Hey,
no,
you're not even allowed to shoot.
We're defense,
defense,
running drills,
drill,
drill.
We never scrimmaged.
And the first time I played in a real game,
I,
it was the first time I played real game.
I went down the court and like called the play and expected to be able to
execute the play that we had run the little pattern and the,
the uh,
other point guard just pick me off.
I was in seventh or eighth grade.
He just picked off every pass I through.
I was just,
because I'd never done Randori on the basketball court.
Never scrimmaged,
never played,
you know,
just got balance.
Those two.
All right.
Uh,
next back to the book.
Next,
I would like to briefly discuss free practice involving throwing and grappling
techniques,
which I will refer to buy.
They're Japanese names.
So the two Japanese names and he's going to use her cough.
Khatami Waza and Naga Waze.
Now,
now Waza means technique,
right?
And you probably knew that a lot of us,
we are,
a lot of us in Jujitsu,
we talk about,
or we we what we know about judo,
we talk about Newaza.
Okay.
And he was Waa z a Nawaz it means of groundwork.
That's what it means.
Mat work basically is what I mean.
I think.
I think the end,
he actually means like laying down or sleeping or something like that.
So it means you're down on the ground.
Khatami Waza is the Khatami was,
it is like the grappling part,
but you're not necessarily,
you're not necessarily laying down in all grappling positions.
So that's why they call it Khatami walls.
But,
but Nagi Waza is the throws.
All right,
so here we go.
Back to the book.
When I was training,
I practiced,
Khatami wasn't quite a bit,
but after coming to appreciate Naga Waza,
I came to believe that Nagi was,
he should be in facade,
in the technical training aspects of judo.
This does not mean I considered Khatami Waza to be useless,
of course,
but I stress practicing Naga Waza first followed then by Khatami was a,
so he focused on the throwing techniques.
This is because doing Khatami was the first hinders progress in Nagi Waza.
While it makes sense that learning Naga Waza first makes it easier to remember,
Khatami was as at a later stage when I established code ICAN,
I encourage the practice of Nagi Gwoza precisely for that reason.
As a result at that time,
a great,
great number of experts in Nagu Aza were fostered in the early years of the code
icon as a result of emphasizing Naga Waza.
However,
Khatami Waza gradually became neglected.
That's very interesting.
So anyone that knows anything about judo and Jujitsu,
one of the biggest differences is in Jujitsu we focused a ton on groundwork.
Too much.
Hm.
Well,
you could say too much,
right?
Because there's,
there's,
there's Jujitsu people that don't know how to take someone down and that's very
problematic.
So he's saying that,
hey,
he focused on that and you can kind of hear what he's saying.
So if you,
it's real easy to ignore the standup when you realize how affected the ground
game is.
And you also realize that if you,
if you understand how to take the person down the,
then you're going to get in good positions and all that.
And so he just kind of leaned in that direction and says that it ends up getting
a little bit neglected.
And also if you don't know the rules of judo,
emphasize the takedowns because of the rules or judo.
If I take you down,
if I throw you with the Nippon,
which means something,
some other body parts other than your feet touches the ground before your feet
do it during a throat.
I when automatically instant win,
it's like a submission.
And so because of that,
they say they practice a lot of standoff.
Whereas in Jujitsu you can get thrown 10 times and you can still catch person in
a triangle.
You when you've been on the ground,
doesn't matter.
And you can get pinned in judo too.
If you get held down for 30 seconds,
about 30 I think 30 seconds on on your back,
you getting pinned,
you lose.
That doesn't happen in Jiu Jitsu.
You can have someone across side to own you for four,
seven,
eight minutes,
just you haven't even moved,
you didn't lose and you sneak out of there and grab a little camera and get the
victory.
All right,
back to look at the code icon.
We study and practice techniques with the purpose of using mental and physical
energy most fit,
most effective Lee in order to achieve one's goal,
no matter what the endeavor,
which is the basic principle of judo,
and he's going to talk about this a ton.
The basic principles of judo is like efficiency,
so those in training do not merely,
now we'll put this is so important.
Those in training do not merely imitate the actions of the master or practice
without understanding the reasons behind what they are doing,
but rather considering the methods and train accordance with detailed
principles.
For that reason,
what once took five or six years to achieve can now be accomplished in three
years.
This is huge in Jujitsu.
And I saw this transition take place when I started learning Jujitsu,
we learned moves.
Now everyone teaches concepts.
I mean you still teach moves,
but if you don't know the principles of them,
and it's the same thing when I was teaching guys in the teams,
like you teach them a maneuver on the battlefield that you can learn the
mechanics of the move on the battlefield.
But if you don't understand the why,
those mechanics are important than it doesn't make,
you don't even have,
you don't have it.
You don't get it.
Same thing in the business world.
You can tell someone like,
hey,
here's what you should tell your subordinates right now.
But that technique you,
they can use it and it'll work.
Okay.
But that's nothing compared to saying,
here's why it's important that you tell your subordinates this thing and here's
how you want to lead them.
That's what gives them the game is when they understand the principles,
you know?
Yeah.
That's why those introductory courses are so critical.
And I'm talking about do you do to help see where you get a new guy,
first day guy and he jumps in a class and the class they're teaching,
you know,
the mechanics of a certain move.
Meanwhile everyone in the class,
they're not first day people,
they know the concepts behind it,
but they come in and it's just,
it's a just a different language.
It doesn't stick.
Yeah.
You could mechanical.
It's like trying to teach someone,
if you,
if you had a non native English speaker and you walk in and you're going to
teach him,
you know,
a vocabulary word.
Yeah.
Which is like,
you know audacious,
right.
He has no context to put that in.
That's not the word to teach him.
He doesn't even know how to say I.
Yeah,
so when you start teaching someone Omoplata and they don't understand what an
arm lock are is they're going to have issues.
Yeah.
That's like the fundamentals.
Do you want ketchup with that?
Teach someone who doesn't know any English,
do you want catch with,
teach them that
and then send them out.
He doesn't know when to use that.
You know,
I know how to say it when you're not just going to roll into the post office and
be like,
Hey,
do you want ketchup with that?
It doesn't make sense.
No,
it doesn't usable.
Back to the book,
various records and accounts had been passed down over the ages with regard to
the true meaning of Jujitsu.
Then he's talking about the actual word Jujitsu,
but few of them are accurate.
It can be said though that the name apparently derived from the expression Jew
Yoko go Osha shoe,
which can be trained,
laid,
translated as softness,
controls hardness.
This expression needs closer attention.
Let's assume I have an opponent who possesses power of out to the value of 10
whereas I must face this opponent with power only to the value of seven when my
opponent thrusted me with all of his energy,
it follows that if I resist,
I will be overcome.
Even if I expend all my power.
If,
however,
rather than resist my more powerful opponent,
I adjust and adapt to his energy and pull back.
He will fall forward under the strength of his own attack.
His power of 10 will become merely a power of three and he will stumble and lose
his balance.
I will not be pulled off balance and can pull away,
maintain my stance and retained my original power of seven.
In short,
resisting a more powerful opponent will result in your defeat whilst adjusting
you to an evading your opponent's attack will cause him to lose his balance.
His power will be reduced and you will defeat him.
This can apply whatever the relative values of tower,
thus making it possible for weaker opponents to beat significantly stronger
ones.
There you go.
Yes sir.
That's the way it works.
Can a level 10 beat a level looking at a level one beat a level 10.
That's tricky.
There's a,
there's a,
there's a point,
right?
Yeah.
There's a point where like,
yeah,
yeah.
Cause it's,
there's like even that what he's talking about,
I like how he did it in numbers,
like how he did that.
Um,
but the reality is like that it's again,
cool to have the numbers,
but it's not,
they're not absolute numbers.
There's a lot of gray area in there,
so the idea is to take his 10 and use almost like using part of his 10 on top of
your seven cause you're going in the same way,
but it's like how much of that 10 are you going to use?
If you're a one you better,
you'd be using nine you better know master.
Yeah.
You're going to be using a lot of his number.
You know,
this is one of those things.
This is one of those things that I subconsciously learned from Jujitsu and I
applied it all the time,
especially in dealing with relationships and I've talked about on here a million
times of like,
Hey,
don't attack the ego.
Don't attack the strong point.
Right?
Yeah.
That's just complete.
Just as to complete Jujitsu mentality,
that's what it is and it works.
If you tack that strong point,
Sun Tzu Art of war,
2,500 years old,
if you attack the diff heavily defended position,
you're,
you're not going to win.
If you go against a power of 10 and you've only got power seven you're not going
to win.
Not gonna happen.
Even if you use full power,
even if you use full power,
in fact it's going to be worse for you,
especially if the other guy knows he's gonna use that seven,
he's going to use that in addition to his daddy's going to beat you with a 17 to
zero and actually that actually backs up or kind of refers back to your point
where it cannot,
when you say Ken,
a level one beat a level 10 so a level,
if they both know Jujitsu or Judah Ben and you know it's way cause he knows the
same thing as you.
But yeah,
you know,
if you're nine,
if you're better than the guy a fact for sure nine then you know your concerns
start to go up for sure.
No doubt,
no doubt about that.
But I think that's where people,
they get jammed up where they're like,
hey,
what do I thought size didn't matter in Jujitsu.
Oh yeah.
If everyone's doing it,
you did.
Of course,
size matters.
Just like conditions going to matter.
Just like how tall he is.
It matters how strong matters when you all know the Jujitsu.
Yeah.
A Dude said the other day.
Um,
Jujitsu's not important as important in the UFC as it was the guy that just beat
for doom,
big,
tall,
bad ass guy from Russia,
calve cough or something.
Uh,
sorry,
Bro.
Uh,
he,
but he said,
hey,
it's not as important anymore.
And the fact that you're right,
you know,
it's not as important because everybody knows about it.
So yeah,
it's not as important as you go.
You roll in there without knowing any Jujitsu,
you're going to get submitted.
Yeah,
exactly.
All right.
Back to the book,
there's a popular parable that goes,
thus
a Jujitsu CTCA,
which means it Jujitsu practitioner was grabbed by a sumo wrestler.
At that point,
that Jujitsu Qca said,
you're a sumo wrestler,
yet you can't grab any tighter than that.
Angered the sumo wrestler,
attempted to adjust his grip as he did.
So he loosened it slightly at that moment that you did.
Sukkah quickly load his body and escape from the sumo refs.
Lose grip.
All right,
now there's another,
we're going to talk about this theory called Su Roco.
Shi-Shin cuts to you and I apologize to everyone that speaks Japanese.
I'm sorry,
Tim Ferris.
I'm sorry.
I should have waited for you to come and do this with me so you could correct
me,
but here,
here we go.
One's mental and physical energy must be used most effectively in order to
achieve a certain goal.
That is to say,
one must apply the most effective method or technique for using the mind and
body.
If we use the term sear Yoko for one's mental and physical energy,
this should be expressed to Yoko then cuts to you,
which means best use of one's energy.
We can shorten this simply to sear Yoko Zinio,
which means maximum efficiency,
maximum efficiency.
This means that no matter what the goal,
no matter what the goal,
in order to achieve it,
you must put your mental and physical energy to work in the most effective
manner.
This is like common sense,
right?
But how often are we wasting energy?
How often are we wasting energy?
We're wasting energy all the time.
Back to the book.
When I was a child,
I learned the Jujitsu of the past.
However,
the Jujitsu had no basic principle.
I learned various methods from one teacher.
He taught me how to place my hips and pull to throw an opponent and how to choke
someone,
but he did not teach me anything about what principals were involved or how to
apply those principles.
That's,
I think that's the same that as Jujitsu hit America,
I think everyone was learning like that.
Like here's how you choke someone but you weren't learning the system.
As I studied further,
I found that one one teacher taught differed from a what another taught.
There was no basis upon which to decide which one was correct.
That was the reason I began to make a thorough study of Jujitsu.
Now what I would say about that is you don't need to decide which one is
correct.
Like when you learn an arm bar from one person,
he would learn a long arm bar from someone else.
You're going to learn good things from both of them.
Neither one of them is correct and one of them might be correct in this
situation or with this body style and the other one's correct in different
situation with a different body style.
I think if we looked at Kainos personality traits,
like he's a guy that's real orderly and I think that's,
yeah,
that's,
he's a real guy like Jordan Peterson when people would put them in the high
conscientious and hi,
hi.
An orderly as a very orderly person.
And so for him,
like there's a right answer and there's a wrong answer.
And I think you see that in judo and that's why judo is much more disciplined,
highly disciplined.
Like go to a judo competition.
There are no yelling it's gonna go to,
did you get to competition?
It's may have.
Yeah.
Right.
And they've tried to tighten that up.
They try and make it less crazy,
but they haven't succeeded to just use crazy competitions are crazy.
Judo competitions are not like that.
Yeah Bro.
Did you see there's a clip,
a doodle clip on online,
wherever I saw it,
but it's a clip.
So this guy wins.
Right?
The real dramatic.
When like maybe he wasn't supposed to win or I don't know,
maybe it an upset,
maybe not.
Or maybe it was the finals,
I don't know.
But it was a real dramatic way and he wins and he's like,
you know how the yell and they'd be all happy what he did that any kind of stood
over that guy.
Oh,
just for a second.
Like a split pretty short DQ.
Dq?
Yeah.
Just like that man in Jujitsu.
Mm.
And we see that all day.
That's,
see that's,
that's the,
that's one of the reasons I wanted to talk about this.
It's like that is a quality thing.
You know,
it's too,
and I guess this is different on the east coast or west coast.
The east coast.
Like one of my buddies,
Joe,
he came and watched some wrestling with maybe some high school wrestling and
they pass the,
I forget what that they penalize
people like,
oh no,
you're allowed to do that.
Like they're strict.
When you get done,
when you get done,
uh,
wrestling,
you just got pinned.
You get up,
you get to sending them out,
you put your hand out,
shake hands.
That's it.
No complaining to the ref.
There's all this other crap.
No,
you do what you're supposed to do and that's awesome because that,
you know what that teaches?
People teach people how to control their emotions.
Yeah.
Huh?
I remember him Pop Warner,
you know,
my only frame of reference was watching football on TV,
NFL,
spiking the ball,
doing the icky shuffle.
Back in my day.
[inaudible] woods.
Anyway,
back did it,
and so,
you know,
we played Pop Warner football my first year.
I knew that our coach was super disciplined,
like the kind where you had to,
everyone had to wear high white socks,
white shoe.
Like,
Hey,
there's a real discipline.
And I'd see other teams then they different color shoes,
all this stuff.
That's all I knew though.
So it was clear you couldn't spike the ball,
you couldn't do any dance or whatever.
You give the ball to the ref.
That's,
that's it.
When you make a touchdown.
So we played this team that will remain nameless and they go,
they do.
You don't want to bring up the old rivalries.
It's going to happen.
They make a,
actually it was a team from out of town and they,
he spiked the ball.
A little kids spike the ball and does the thing or whatever.
Straight up flag.
It's a,
it's a penalty.
You could actually,
even in college,
it's like that.
Oh Great.
I don't know.
Yeah.
In College football,
it's like that you can do,
you can do more for sure.
Um,
but yeah,
pop Warner,
anything.
If you do anything,
you throw the ball,
you put your hands up for too long.
If you put your hands up for too long after you make it on,
that's a penalty.
Unsportsmanlike conduct.
That's legit.
Right?
I think so.
Especially as little kids.
Especially even as big kids.
Yeah.
My Dad used to say stuff.
When you're on your emotion,
you're a professional.
Um,
this is what he said.
When you're a professional football player,
you can,
and you make a touchdown.
Uh,
something about like,
that's your job or whatever.
So yeah,
you have the right to be happy about it.
That was kind of,
but when I think about it now,
it's like,
shoot,
if you're a professional,
you focus on your profession.
Do you think so?
I guess it's whatever your philosophy is and you can say like UFC,
I mean it's really cool.
It's so much cooler when someone wins and they'd just start like,
check.
Yeah.
It's like,
yeah,
there and just destroy someone and they're just like,
thanks.
Good match.
That is true.
I know we all want to see the high,
that's the thing I,
and jumping on top of the case that sells tickets and blah,
blah,
but there's nothing better than just a cold blooded killer that just comes out.
And,
and you know what's interesting is sometimes fighters do it.
Um,
I think I was watching cowboy Serona the other day.
He's like,
knock some grounds and walked away like it was nothing.
Yeah.
I do this every single day.
I was like,
yeah,
but they don't show that clip or like Mark Hunt.
Yeah.
Mark Hunt just does those walkaway knockout,
just knocks dude out.
Just walks away again.
Yeah.
Can I get my piece of chicken now?
I'm hungry.
But the,
the reason that those are so cool,
like fate or that's great example,
the way where he's just,
no,
he's not getting hyped up for the fight,
that hyped up afterwards,
you know,
no emotions,
cold know that that gets,
that seems more appealing because it's in contrast to all the hype,
all the High Lord,
this guy getting hyped up and whatever.
So if everyone was like that,
he would be less,
it was still would be cool.
But even then,
I'm probably just comparing it to like how I know it now.
You can't not go hyper and Conor McGregor gets pumped out.
Exactly right.
So,
you know,
it's,
there's a,
there's a dichotomy there.
There's a dichotomy.
I think the preferred method though is cold blooded.
Yeah.
But when you,
and this is really what it is and this goes for the NFL to bed.
Yeah.
For sure.
Um,
it's,
it's a show.
Got to remember that gets it.
Exactly right.
So,
and that makes sense too for the NFL where just go sit around and watch old
fight or flight.
So,
you know,
soccer was kind of like the soccer Robert didn't celebrate without soccer.
Sakharov yes,
of course.
Yes.
Soccer Robos.
Pretty cool.
Yeah,
totally cold blooded.
Yeah.
But just how you say,
man,
like Connor and like these guys who,
who do put on a show,
that's kind of cool to see what I'm saying.
All right.
Back to the book.
In the end I learned from various teachers in various schools,
but when one method of instruction different from another,
I had difficulty determining how to resolve those differences.
As I studied further,
I came up with the principals I've described.
In order to achieve your goals,
you must put your energy to use most effectively.
Again.
Um,
I'll just say that you don't have to choose like,
this one's right in,
this one's wrong.
You need to absorb both those methodologies and have them both in your toolkit
because you might need them.
You know what I'm saying?
Yeah.
It's kind of like having the metric ranch sockets and the,
you know,
Oh yeah,
yeah.
And the other one.
Then you've got the other one's got a need.
We've got the one,
the other one,
you come across a bolt.
That's metric,
right?
It'd be ready for that.
Uh,
here's,
here's some stuff that's interesting.
Calisthenics are generally based on physiology and anatomy,
so they do not result in the development of unbalanced body,
nor are they harmful to the internal organs,
but they are not without,
without drawbacks because each individual movement has no meaning.
And because calisthenics have no secondary benefits,
they are uninteresting calisthenics or widely used in Japan and abroad.
But few students continue to do them after grade,
graduating from school.
This is because they are a meaningless form of exercise and not have any
practical use.
No matter how much they are taught in schools,
if people would not continue to practice them,
there is video,
very little value in teaching them
cold blooded his vehicle,
but in a dig it.
So what should be done?
We need to adopt the strong points of calisthenics and compensate for their
shortcomings.
Of course,
there are various possibilities,
but for now I've come up with these two ideas.
First.
The first is calisthenics that incorporate training for the defense for the
defense against.
So the first one is like you come up with calisthenics that represent movements
that are from fighting.
Right.
So like a classic is a sprawl sprawl.
Yeah.
Go do some sprawls you want to get in good shape.
Go do some sprawls incorporate that.
One of the workouts I used to do with my kids when they were little is they'd
have to do five sprawls and Max pullups every minute on the minute for five
minutes.
Just five minutes.
See how many popes they could get sued you.
Five sprawls and you use many poets as you can to see how many.
This is a brutal workout.
Go try that one.
Yeah,
you don't,
you don't even need to be,
uh,
an eight year old kid.
You can be a 46 year old man.
Go hit that for five minutes.
Five sprawls Max pullups go.
But he's a good workout for kids.
Yeah,
but legit.
But anyway,
sprawls that's an exercise where it debt reflects exactly the movement that you
would do on the mat.
Now here we go back to the book.
My other idea could be called dance style and I'm not going to get into what he
talks about it.
He's basically saying like,
hey,
you come up with dance moves that are fun,
that work your body.
And what I thought of immediately when I,
when I thought when I read that I was like thinking about all the,
all the uh,
I guess is bboys and break dancing.
The same thing be bullies do break dancing.
So it's like judo and judo,
so bboys breakdown.
So like the 10th planet guys,
a bunch of the 10 finding guys came from the break dancing background and they
have the physical attributes,
the flexibility,
the strength from that.
And it turns out to be awesome for Jujitsu.
So there's a good,
and you can find that with gymnastics.
People to like,
yeah,
like gymnastics,
here's a skill.
But I guess his point is in his mind that's now fun somehow see in my mind like
it's not fun what the break tenancy like to me doing a break dance move compared
to doing a pushup.
Yeah.
You'd rather do the pushup?
Well,
I mean there's,
there's not a huge difference,
right?
Yeah,
yeah.
Breakdown.
It's pretty fun.
I used to do that when I was young.
Did you have a parachute pants?
Yeah.
Richie Martinez and Martinez.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
No,
the main guys.
Yeah.
Well they're,
they're,
they're bad estrogens.
You guys and there be boys.
Yeah.
And that,
that is what they attribute their skills,
their skills developing so quickly,
so quickly.
And when you,
when you think about it,
man,
it's absolutely true because you think of break dancing moves,
like how you can spend on your back and do it.
Like all this stuff like to spin on your back.
You know,
these guys who go inverted and do all this stuff where they have really good
control of it.
They're like spacial workers in their buddy.
Yeah.
You know,
so these breakdancing guys,
they come in with level 10 of that,
you know,
and well,
wrestlers obviously come in at a high level gymnast.
Anyone that's really good at gymnastics has that same kind of awareness in the
handsome,
crazy strength,
you know?
So yeah,
maybe that is a good thing for the,
for the judo players come up with some kind of a good dance.
A dance.
Well,
what about Cap Wetta cut boy.
Cause capital letter was,
it was fighting disguised as dancing.
Yes sir.
Yeah,
you knew it was,
it was the African slaves in Brazil.
And if you notice,
I know this because they did a whole,
it's not a thesis,
what do you call it?
Like a,
anyway,
I think in college,
but they did a thing on college and capital [inaudible] and so I don't want to
go into a whole long thing,
but good.
If you go early copywriter was only legs.
You know why?
Because they,
a lot of the time they'd be tied up,
hands behind their back so that,
yeah,
so they came up with is fighting system desta disguise it as dancing to use
against their captors.
It's very interesting.
That is interesting.
B Boys,
people sweater.
A couple of other guys.
Jeff Higgs went from Jujitsu to cap wet.
Fabio,
Fabio Santos or old teacher was like Higgs.
You're the only person that's ever gone from Jujitsu.
He kept training Jujitsu Incorporated Kappa Wetta.
Yeah.
Even the Katrina,
Katrina does same thing.
I think he had none at all.
I think he kept that most,
most people would find cap wedding gall.
That seems cool.
But then you get choked out.
You're like,
I'm gonna learn to just,
yeah,
yeah.
That goes,
man.
You ever seen like a cop would at like,
uh,
um,
performance or whatever?
Men,
there's this,
it's gymnastics and whenever you want to call it.
Yeah,
man,
it's really impressive.
It's the yield.
And I'm referring to this guy that you said he'd put on a couple at a show every
Wednesday at this club I worked at in Hawaii.
And so he do these like flips and somersaults and stuff like that and it looks
like,
oh,
he messed up that somersault,
but that was part of the move.
See what I'm saying?
So he,
instead of sticking the landing,
he doesn't stick the landing.
He rolls into the next move,
you know?
So it's this big string of just real fluid,
Numa Elis.
It's kind of captivating.
I can see how that would benefit you.
Okay.
No.
Did
keep that in mind.
All right.
Back to the book.
There's no need to reject traditional form of exercise.
Those who enjoy them should do them.
My doctrine is very simple,
highly recommend what is best without rejecting things of the past.
So I do not particularly opposed Japan's conventional methods of physical
education,
but I would like to devise the best form of physical education,
recommend as many people as possible,
take it up thus resulting in a form of physical education that at the same time
achieves worthwhile goals.
That is cool,
right?
Like that's one of the coolest things about Jujitsu is you are getting in shape
and you are learning how to choke people out,
which is really beneficial fig.
And that's for all the people that say,
well,
I want to start Jujitsu but I need to get in shape first.
No,
you don't.
You just need to start Jujitsu and you'll get in shape along the way.
Back to the book.
The prosperity of a nation can be hope for only with an energized populace.
That
vitality and that vitality depends on the mental and physical training of the
people.
The powerful nations of the world have explored every avenue in order to build
their national strength and they are paying particular attention to physical
education and endeavoring to promote vitality of their citizens through their
own unique methods.
Well that sounds good and it was true at one time,
but in America right now we're getting pretty weak on physical education.
Need to step it up,
step it up,
step it up.
You ever seen that video of the old school,
they did some experimental gym class somewhere in California and like the crazy
obstacle where this is like in the,
maybe the forties or the fifties and they had crazy obstacle courses and they
had this and like every kid looked like a complete beast and you're like,
yeah,
why wouldn't you do that?
Why wouldn't gym class at school be an hour long of hardcore physical putting
out why would it not be that way?
Right?
Yeah.
You know why?
Because people don't have it that that's insulting to my child because he's not
a great athlete.
Well your kid's not going to be a better athlete if they don't start training
hard.
Right.
The lake wasn't get in the game.
Yeah,
I agree.
So what,
what is it though?
The kid,
the kid like okay,
we're going to do pushups today.
Right.
And you know,
Johnny did a hundred pushups.
Meanwhile I can only do two.
So I feel bad that this is not my self esteem.
I don't want to put you on the spot and you know what?
We're just going to not do pushups.
In fact,
you know what we're going to do for PE?
Weave baskets.
Basket weaving.
Yeah,
but even isn't the eight isn't the whole grading system.
I know we're going to use a little different things,
but isn't the whole grading system in school like that anyway?
Hey Johnny over there got a yeah,
it is right now.
But you know,
there's the universities for sure that have like,
well there's no grades here.
Yeah.
Because we don't,
this isn't about a grade.
Yeah.
Actually the like no actually becoming,
you know what?
We don't,
you know,
it makes my kids mad.
My kids will be like,
I got to,
I got a 96 on the math test and I'm like,
what was the class average?
Or who did you lose to anyone?
And they're like,
well,
it's just,
you know,
if everyone got a 96 I don't care.
Your average,
I don't know.
Maybe you should care.
Maybe you should.
Maybe you should be impressed with the teacher.
The teacher is so good at teepees.
They,
when they test these kids,
these kids score almost perfect on the test,
on the material that they taught.
Dang.
That's one good teacher right there.
Yeah.
Well I'd be impressed with a teacher,
but I wouldn't be impressed with my kid if they just got the same as everyone
else.
They need to step it up.
What if they all got hung up it up?
What if they all got hundreds?
Okay,
they got a hundred okay.
Like still not impressed.
Well,
it's,
it's a good job,
but I'm not impressed.
I'm impressed.
Hundred perfect.
Score on a test.
My Edit,
my what?
My little daughter will come home and she'll be like,
Dad,
I got a 94 on the math test it.
I'll be like,
which one did you miss your,
my wife would be like,
teller.
She did a great job.
I'm not going to lie to her,
whatever.
That is a good job.
All right.
Okay,
cool.
We'll leave it at that.
You know it's funny as I know you're really not like that because I see.
You know it's funny is I do say that to my kids with this joking.
It is fun.
Yeah.
Like you're like at our peak when we were at my house,
the pool,
everyone's jumping in the pool doing their dives.
Then you're like,
it's like joking Jocko.
You can totally tell.
You're like,
good dive,
but I want to see improvement in this area and this is like over it.
It's good.
I see what you're doing there.
We've got to have fun with it.
Sure.
Back to the book,
intellectual training I was talking about intellectual train.
Intellectual training involves both the acquisition of knowledge and the
cultivation of mental power and where I was.
One can not discuss these entirely as entirely separate things.
It is nevertheless true that people with a great deal of knowledge do not
necessarily have exceptional powers of reasoning or judgment.
That's important.
Just because you went to some course doesn't mean that you know,
doesn't mean you have good judgment,
so you can have people that are well read and well educated,
but they don't have any common sense that that's what,
that's how I translate this thing here.
The cultivation of these powers does not in itself entailed becoming
knowledgeable,
so in fact these two things can be looked at separately,
so there's a big difference between having information and having,
I guess we'd say wisdom.
What does he call it?
Reasoning and judgment.
I'd call reasoning and judgment combined together.
I'd call that wisdom
and now he talks about moral education back to the book.
In one respect,
moral education must be carried out from the aspect of knowledge.
That is to say it is necessary to know intellectually what is good and what is
evil.
It was also necessary to develop the intelligence to distinguish right from
wrong in various complex situations.
Thus it is necessary to teach the ability to determine good from bad to
discriminate what is right from what is wrong.
This is something that I think we're getting away from like,
Hey,
you know what that's actually wrong.
Like the whole idea you've,
you've,
you hear people and I think it's,
I think they wrap this around a political conversation or a political viewpoint
of there's some people that say like no evil actually exists and some people
just say,
well know people are different and people are raised differently and all that.
I'm,
I'm one of the people that like I believe evil exists and I think you can teach
and you have to teach people how to tell the difference between right and wrong.
There's some things that are wrong.
Yeah.
For some things in the world that are wrong and you shouldn't do them.
Strangely it was talking to jade pretty in depth about that idea applies to a
bunch of things were
even saying,
okay,
things are right and things are wrong.
That's,
that's like one way of La.
You know what the,
okay,
so these people that that say,
well people are different.
There's no real absolute right or wrong.
The thing is there,
they have a point with that.
But here's the thing,
they're not talking about the same thing you're talking about like the,
we have a societal standard,
so and see it got super complex.
So obviously it's not the time,
but think about this.
Let's say a fat person right
there
fat.
Everyone can see that they're fat,
they know they're fat kind of thing.
Right?
And some people would say it's wrong to indicate or to point out that that
person's fat in front of people,
even though the fact is that they are okay,
is it right or wrong to point that out?
It's rude.
Exactly right.
So and so is it right to be rude?
You're was it right or wrong?
Total scenario dependent thing.
Who is the person?
Right?
So the point is,
yeah,
the point is there's a societal standard and usually it's established just like
beat,
like beating your kids in certain societies is right in certain societies is
wrong.
So sure.
The more extreme the behavior,
the easier it is to discern.
Okay.
That's for all that.
I think there's a,
there's a line that I take is,
and it can call.
Yeah.
And it goes all the way down to like almost like a human nature,
like understanding of of heat,
like basic human needs and Sam Harris,
he'll say he talks about suffering like suffering and wellbeing.
That's the two things.
If something promotes or or advocate suffering for like no reason why,
you know,
he goes into it,
then that's how you can discern good and evil.
Okay.
So,
but at the end of the day it goes down to a standard,
like a specific standard.
Yeah.
But I what I,
I guess you're saying the same thing.
I'm sorry.
Yeah.
Which is like you need to teach people and,
and explain what the value system is too young to people.
Oh,
back to the book.
In another sense,
moral education must be carried out from the aspect of the emotions.
Even if you can distinguish right from wrong intellectually.
If you are not trained emotionally to like what is good and dislike,
what is evil,
your ability to do good and reject evil will be lacking.
So if morals are not cultivated both intellectually and emotionally,
good results cannot be achieved.
This is big stuff.
Yeah.
This is heavy stuff
back to the book.
Furthermore,
even if you do try to do good and reject evil,
if your willpower is weak,
the opposite result will often occur.
Therefore,
training of the will must also be an element of moral education.
A weak willpower can result in the inability to do what you know is right or the
inability to prevent doing what you know is wrong.
Boom.
This is the very important stuff
a week.
Willpower will,
you'll allow bad things to happen.
Yup.
Choosing the short term pay off over the long term.
Another good example,
back to the book,
it is also important not to look the over,
not to overlook the element of habit.
Even if you intend to do good.
If you have not developed the habit of doing so,
your best intentions will easily be corrupted and even the best intentions of
rejecting evil can fail.
Have you have not developed the habit of doing so.
For that reason,
you must endeavor to cultivate good habits,
love what is good and reject what is evil on a daily basis.
You know what?
This supports,
this supports that whole,
you know when,
when I talk about the fact that like if you make good decisions,
like if you wake up early,
that goes,
that's a habit and that helps you,
that strengthens your ability to reject weakness.
Whereas if you sleep in your lazy,
you hit the snooze button,
you're double fist and donuts into your mouth,
guess what?
You're going to be weak.
Then I'll tell you something else.
At a and R I had been talking about this or I've been thinking about this,
I've been talking about it,
but I've been thinking about this,
right?
Okay.
The way,
the,
the way that you live,
every little thing that you do,
like those actions that you take on a daily basis,
that's who you are and if you don't train correctly,
if you don't live correctly,
when the moment of truth comes,
you won't be able to execute correctly.
Yeah.
The way you,
it's like it's a classic of the way you treat you,
the way you train.
Is it how you fight,
right?
Yeah.
If you don't train hard,
you're not going to fight hard.
If you push yourself mentally when the time comes you will to push yourself.
You'll be able to push yourself mentally.
If your weekend training,
you'll be weekend war.
That's the way it is.
Yeah.
Those very well put sir.
Yes
we are.
I was talking to Jay last night,
like I said,
and that's what we were talking about too.
That's what I brought up cause he was really excited about learning all these
new things about calculus and all this stuff.
Right?
Because he's into AI or machine learning and whatnot.
So I was like,
okay,
you know,
you're,
you're really excited about learning this stuff,
which is good by the way.
And we're just,
I was,
I wasn't necessarily talking about him,
but um,
but he just used him as the example.
So he,
I was like,
okay,
so what is,
what is it like your,
so are you applying this to like your work now or your life or whatever or are
you just fired up about learning it?
So it's like you can learn about
okay.
Everything in the whole wide universe,
right?
But if you don't put it into action,
whenever it's like your habits,
like what you do that that's who you are.
Like it,
let's say you're,
you're,
you,
I dunno.
Well actually I think you're saying something different.
I know what you're saying.
What you're saying is absolutely true too.
I'm saying little,
the little things matter is what I'm saying.
The way you live is the way you live is what I'm saying.
Yeah.
Okay.
What you're saying is also important.
Like,
Hey,
you got this.
What are you going to do with it?
Yeah.
That's where you're saying,
and that also is important.
Like,
okay,
well you worked for this,
but now what are you going to do with it?
You got this gift.
What are you gonna do with this gift?
You've got this talent.
What are you gonna do with his talent?
You got this education.
What do you do with his education?
Those are also important.
Yeah,
and what I'm saying is if you don't develop the habit of putting things into
place and being efficient at working hard,
you can take those gifts,
those talents and that education.
You can piss it away.
That's what I'm saying.
Yeah.
If you're used to taking the easy road,
you get that knowledge.
You don't do anything with it.
Yeah.
So live your life with intent.
That's what I'm saying.
Every day,
every little decision you make matters.
It matters.
Matters what you do.
Yeah.
Expanding this out a little bit.
Back to the book.
If each member of a group helps others in ax selflessly,
the group can be harmonious and act as one.
Accordingly,
the group can make the best use of its energy just like an individual.
This principle remains true even in the case of a complex society with a
population of millions.
Yeah,
yeah.
Help each other out.
This is very,
this is what this is.
You know this is like a seal team,
right?
This is like a seal platoon.
You help each other.
You support each other.
That's what makes you good.
Hmm.
Here's another one.
Let's say someone draws a sword on you and this is getting back into training
global.
Let's say someone draws a sword on you.
Any hesitations in your actions will result in you being injured or killed.
You must react automatically.
Instinctively justice.
When you blink impulsively,
when a fly approaches your eye,
you must dodger attacker an instant.
In order to do this,
you must practice.
Practice this as physical education and train on a regular basis to build up
your body while also undergoing martial arts training.
So I like this idea of a fly getting in your eye,
right?
The flight doesn't hate your eye.
You Blink.
That's what happens.
You have the instinct and what's cool,
I see this with extreme ownership.
When people first hear about the concept like it's foreign to them.
At Utah,
you've talked about this,
how once you started thinking about it,
you'd see like Amy excuse that someone makes,
you're like,
Oh man,
this guy's not taking ownership.
That's just an excuse and then you see it in yourself and when that becomes your
instinct because you're living that way,
well then it's very easy to spot.
It's also easier to maintain.
Yeah.
That's why the little things matter.
Echo.
Yes,
sir.
Back to the book,
judo began with a study of martial arts and then it gradually became clear that
it could be applied to physical education,
intellectual training,
moral education,
social engagement management,
and people's everyday lives.
Some people believe that judo means simply practicing at the Dojo.
This is applying the principle of judo at the Dojo when practicing defense
against attack and though it certainly one aspect of judo is only a small part
of it.
With judo in every endeavor,
you must imagine the best goal and use your mental and physical energy the most
effective manner in order to accomplish that goal.
For that reason.
Judo is not merely a martial art,
but rather the basic principle of human behavior.
It is wrong to assume judo ends in the Dojo,
so he's saying,
apply this everywhere.
I'm saying you should do that.
You can do it with Jujitsu.
Yeah.
Now we're going back into this sphere.
Yoko Zenu.
Certain teachings have a long tradition,
so most people accept them,
but when people do not understand why they are taught a certain way,
conflicts,
conflicts can sometimes arrive,
arise to give example.
Virtually no one doubts that diligence is a good thing,
right?
No one doubts.
The diligence is a good thing.
If diligence is always a good thing it falls at.
There can be no situation in which being diligent is bad,
but if you are diligent in an irresponsible manner,
you will spend a great deal of effort on something that is not very useful and
expand the energy required to do something good.
Wastefully you must carefully choose something for which diligence is suited.
Even when we do what we believe to be best over doing something can be harmful.
When students stay up late reading a book because they're teachers,
parents or society has deemed at best that they should read it.
This is certainly diligence,
but it's also detrimental to their health to read for so long.
Conversely,
you cannot do things halfheartedly or randomly,
so
you got to stay balanced.
Let us turn to the into an annoying yet pervasive habit.
People all too often display complaining.
What is the point of complaining?
It is certainly no fun for those who have to listen to the complaints.
The energy use to make an unpleasant complaints can certainly not be considered
Siri Yoku Zinio.
Okay.
Rather,
all the energy used to complain or grumble should be expended more usefully.
This means ridding oneself of unpleasant feelings and refraining from harboring
ill will towards others in this end,
in the end,
this will result in putting one's energy to the best use,
not only for oneself but also for the betterment of society.
This principle should be applied every day at all times,
okay?
Don't waste your energy on stuff that doesn't matter.
Back to the book.
If people are always aware of their current situation and set a standard for
their future based on doing what will benefit themselves in society and
continually regulate their behavior,
they can be satisfied with their lives at all times.
When you try to do this,
you will find that your future prospects are always bright.
That is because you are doing is best.
How,
how common sense is this?
Right?
And it's so common sense,
but how,
how many people do you know that follow this path?
That's the question.
Yeah.
That goes back to
how you say that idea of being detached.
When you detached it's common sense but when you're in the game it's not common
sense because of how you,
just like how it said,
how you feel like you know like even complaining for example,
like you could ask,
I don't say literally everyone,
but you get out of several one and be like,
hey complaining.
Is that useful?
Is that good to do?
Is that fine to do complain?
Yes or no?
Everyone's all no,
no,
no.
Why does everyone complain then?
Cause when you're in the gang complaining if you can feel better or whatever
you picked up on it very well because he says if people are always aware of
their current situation,
meaning they need to be detached and then set a standard for the future based on
doing things that just think it's the same thing thick.
Is it smart to do things that will benefit themselves and society continually
continue to regulate your behavior so that you're satisfied with your life?
And I'll think of course that makes sense.
Sure.
Why don't we do it?
We get off the path.
We get on the slip
free slope.
We start losing our awareness of our,
what are the current state will have?
Yeah.
Uh,
current situation,
current situation.
I don't understand it.
Yeah.
This is interesting.
Through judo we are teaching a principle that can work together with the highest
principles of Buddhism and Christianity and the exhaustive studies of
philosophers.
One which like other great philosophies and religions can be put into action.
This principle of judo offers a basic principle that can provide a sound answer
for every situation and every question.
The easiest way to master this basic principle is to practice the Waza of judo
and to embark on the dough the way that is because through practice that
incorporates both a martial art and physical education.
One can learn a method for making the most effective use of one's mental and
physical energy.
Then one naturally learns how to apply this method to every aspect of human
affairs.
I believe that this basic principle is the most appropriate method for resolving
various moral issues.
Man,
he puts a lot of weight on the judo.
A lot of weight on the judo.
Yeah.
With regard to our daily activities and social interaction,
the teaching of serial [inaudible] Zinio means bringing about maximum results
through the use of every sort of energy.
For this reason,
human faults like anger,
for example,
violate this principle.
Becoming angry consumes mental energy.
How does anger benefit you or anyone else?
The result of anger are invariably a depletion of mental energy and being looked
down on or disliked by others.
By following the principle of cereal code Zinio.
People will not be able to get angry.
Being disappointed or troubled by failures or setbacks or harboring grievances
are also ways in which mental energy is consumed.
Arguments,
fights.
All of these are violations of Siri,
Oco,
Zeniah,
those who practice judo must take great care to follow this teaching,
no matter what the situation,
there is only one path that people must follow.
In every case,
the only courses to consider.
What is the right thing to do and proceed in that direction.
What is the right thing to do and do that you know
what does the right thing to do and do that that's what you should do regardless
of how you feel.
Yes,
I have coined a phrase that I regularly say to people,
there is only one path in life.
Conducting yourself in accordance with this principal on a daily basis is
vitally important.
Though human beings may reach the pinnacle of success,
there is only one path down which to proceed.
That is to say because complacency gives rise to the cause of failure,
you must always consider things carefully until you find the appropriate course
of action and proceed that way.
Even when you fail,
there's only one path down which to proceed.
Even if once you fail and lose heart,
if you regain your courage and find your way along the highest path,
the highest path circumstances will gradually improve.
That's like Jordan Peterson talking,
right?
Hey,
you know,
like get on,
do the right thing to pick a little thing and start improving that thing.
Clean your room because they find their own paths.
Those who practiced judo and who followed the principle of serial cuisine,
you always have a calm spirit.
Enjoy life and our enterprising,
the most advanced mental life can only be achieved when people thoroughly
absorbed this principle.
Sudoku,
Zenu maximum efficiency.
What are you doing that is taking away your energy?
What are you wasting your energy on?
Back to the book a true a person's true value is determined by how much he or
she contributes to society during his or her life and because these very
contributions enable those who strive to protect themselves to achieve this,
the purpose of judo is to perfect yourself so that you can contribute to
society.
This applies to ordinary people as well.
Again,
this is very,
very similar to what Jordan Peterson socks about.
You're like you,
you need to,
if you,
if you fix your world well,
you're impacting everyone's world around you.
This applies to ordinary people as well,
but in particular those who specialize in judo must be expected to act in a way
consistent with the purposes of judo.
When you practiced judo,
you must try to perfect yourself and contribute to society through this practice
and you must emphasize the importance of this during your teachings to others.
Something that seems good because it is near at hand,
may be useless in the future,
whereas in some cases a bit of patients is highly effective in furthering your
lot in the future,
right?
Delayed gratification.
The basis of happiness in life is found not in the pursuit of material gains or
temporary pleasure and true kindness towards one's friends means giving them
serious advice when needed selflessly without fear of offending them.
That one's interesting because I deal with this one a lot,
right?
I deal list with a lot because you got your,
your subordinate that's not doing what they're supposed to do and I just was
having this conversation with a group I was working with and they were real big
on the word transparency of life and I talked about it on the podcast and,
and if here's the question,
like I'm going to be transparent with you,
like,
hey,
echo your videos.
You know they're not good right now.
Like your videos aren't good.
You need to tighten up your videos.
Like does that make,
does that improve our relationship?
Does that make you want to do a good job for me?
Does that make you want to do like get out there and really crush it?
No,
not at all.
So even though I'm being transparent,
does it help our situation?
Does it help?
What we're trying to do.
No it doesn't.
So I need to figure out a way to tell you something.
And normally the best way to do that,
and here's a big hint for everyone that's out there,
if you want to give someone critique that they know that you know they need,
one of the best ways to give them critique is to take ownership of it,
take ownership of the problem.
So I say Echo,
hey,
I feel like I'm not really giving you good guidance on,
on the videos and the way they're coming out.
I want to sit down and talk to you and actually go through like what,
what will the impact that we're trying to have and that I want to have?
And I mean I know you're working hard,
but I feel like I'm not giving you good enough guy.
And so I to sit down with you and try and see if I can be more clear.
Right.
Does that offend you?
No.
Well I know what you're doing now,
but yeah,
no,
I get it.
Yeah,
you're right.
So you take,
if you take ownership of the problem and then you talk about the problem with
the person,
it puts,
it doesn't,
it makes it makes them not have a defensive posture,
which is what you,
which is what you want.
You want.
Don't want them to have a defensive posture.
I actually want to have them have an open mind and be able to listen to what I
say.
They won't listen if you're pointing the finger at them.
Yeah,
they won't listen as well.
They might listen for a little while,
but it won't be a lasting thing.
Maybe years later maybe or something like that won't help the relationship.
We know that and I'm sure
you must remember
that the purpose of expanding a great deal of effort to build a strong body as
to enable you to undertake jobs that you might otherwise be unable to endure.
So when he's talking about there,
he's talking about,
he basically goes on this whole thing about like being big and buff.
Sure.
He's not pro not down for that.
It's not down for the cause.
Like Echo Charles.
He would look at you and think you're wasting too much time on your,
on your bicep curls
might be right.
Yeah.
So that's what he's saying is that he's,
he's all about the functional strength.
You want to be strong so that you can do jobs that you might not be able to
endure if you didn't work hard.
He didn't work out hard.
Hey,
that's a balancing act too.
I know you're going to defend them.
The biceps curls wrong,
but you know how like they say it's even like,
like kind of like,
cause it's bad example,
but you,
he said you want to save your energy essentially for jobs that are like
important.
Right?
So if you know,
he says the reason that you're trying to get strong isn't so you can look big
and buff.
It's so that you can do jobs that you can endure jobs that you wouldn't have
bailed too.
Gotcha.
So that,
that should be the focus of your training.
Functional strength.
That's what he's our,
he's down with the functional strength is this guy I need to super funny bro.
Science,
I think I told this deep bro.
Science life or something like that so that that grows so funny.
And he's talking about functional strength.
He's did,
he said,
so,
you know,
it's jokes or whatever.
And he's like,
yeah,
so good luck.
You can compare your functional strength with my actual strength.
So funny.
But in his mind,
actual strength.
It's like how much you can bench and you know,
you know how it is.
But yeah,
that's the not every time I hear it,
like when a guy starts to like heavily advocating functional strength over like
a,
some,
some lip weightlifter guy or whatever.
I think about that.
That's even though I'm sure this book came out a lot,
you know,
earlier than Bro,
science life,
Shaq,
all right,
back to the book.
Some who practiced judo become overconfident of their health and inevitably fail
to look after themselves.
We must not be careless about where we live,
our clothing or our hygiene.
We should pay great attention to what we eat and drink.
There was a time when people did not deem it a problem to eat and drink to
excess,
but rather we're proud of a prolific,
uh,
proud of being a prolific eater or a heavy drinker.
That way of thinking still persists
and is obviously detrimental to health if you do not take care in regard to
matters of health,
there is no benefit in practicing judo.
Those who practice judo must not only keep this in mind but must also consider
it their duty to remind others
that's bolded it there their duty to remind [inaudible] star next to that little
ass.
This guy again,
this guy is like super orderly and he's,
you know,
just going to tighten people up.
You know,
he's out there going,
don't eat that donut.
Yeah,
well it's one thing to but to the nth degree.
Yeah.
That's like your duty.
Come on Bro.
Yeah,
he,
you know,
it's my duty.
I'm going to go,
you know,
I'm going to go to the mall and buy the food court and you know what's the
funniest,
this is the only thing in the whole book that he says like judo won't help.
Like if you,
if you're not healthy,
it's not,
you don't even train.
He has a thing.
He has a thing like that.
Yeah.
It's a little thing.
What's that called?
A pick a hang up.
Yeah.
Yeah,
yeah.
This is hangup
because judo derives from the martial arts of the past.
It must perpetuate the spirit of other martial arts,
loyalty,
faith,
honor,
and various other virtues were emphasized in the martial arts of the past.
But I can,
we feel their importance even today,
the deterioration of society's morals today is primarily the result of a failure
to emphasize these virtues.
So I believe that those who practice judo in particular must apply themselves to
these matters and restore today's neglected public morals.
He's got another little hang up.
Hang Up.
He's,
but I mean,
obviously I'm pointing this out because we could clearly look at society today
and be like,
yeah,
well guess what?
We were on a slippery slope.
Yeah.
You can tell he feels strongly about that one though,
right there who meet or heal him.
Oh yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
What about me?
Yeah,
it did.
Just,
you had to look on your face indicated that for sure.
That's a whole nother thing.
It's,
it's weird because you go around different pockets of the world in different
pockets of the country and you see various,
various positions on the slippery slope.
Some people hanging on,
but some people are not and they're just slipping and we gotta be careful.
Yeah.
And you get an,
obviously that's a whole nother topic,
but the,
you know,
and you have so many huge,
major,
major forces kind of working against it,
you know,
pushing us down the slippery slope like marketing,
right.
You know,
how like marketing most marketing is to appeal to your most immediate of wants
base delicious,
a double whatever,
you know,
and it's the girl that's showing the delicious burger like,
yeah.
And guess what,
it doesn't even cost that much.
Dang.
You know,
so gratification for cheap.
Yeah,
man.
So you can get it and sex thrown on top of that just to make you feel good,
you know,
whatever,
and that's everything.
So,
you know,
again,
if you're not,
what is it conscious of your situation or whatever it
is.
I think people lose concentration this because most people,
in my opinion,
most people are like,
they kind of know,
you know,
we were like,
we go back to the theory of right and wrong and what's right.
I think most people
are pretty good with it.
Like most people feel pretty like they know what's bay like no,
that's wrong.
Right.
And they know that,
hey,
you know what?
That's a good thing to do.
Right.
I think most people kind of like broadly kind of kind of a would agree with
those things.
Yeah.
The problem is,
and so that's why I think we don't emphasize as much because we think,
you know what,
my,
hey man,
most people pretty much agree with me.
Like it's like the center people of the country right now.
Like,
and the extreme right now,
the extreme left now,
okay,
where are you at?
It's like,
okay,
well those people that are in the middle,
it's like,
yeah,
we,
we kind of figured like,
okay,
pretty much.
And so what happens is once we don't talk about it as much,
well then the people that are on the fringes,
mentally,
they ended up without a compass.
Right.
They just don't even know what's right and what's wrong anymore because people
aren't talking about as much because it doesn't seem like we need to.
I think we might need to.
Yeah.
And why it's right.
Then it comes down to your approach and like all this stuff,
cause you know when you have opposing views,
it's like if you don't do it with the right approach,
you just,
it becomes more about the fight more.
For sure.
So yeah,
I think you're right about that.
I think are,
and are you talking about what people,
most people know right and wrong because there's a difference between like,
just like how you were saying where people know right and wrong,
but they don't always do what's right kind of thing.
Totally.
So is that what you're talking about?
Like when most people,
no,
I'm saying,
I'm saying if you don't teach a kid like,
hey,
when you see someone that needs help you go help them.
Right,
like little old lady crossing the street.
right.
That seems obvious.
Little Old lady cross the street,
she's got a grocery bag.
You,
you go,
okay,
Hey,
can I help you with that grocery bag and you know,
help you put it in your car.
Maybe for you,
you get a little pump while you're at it with that grocery bag.
Hope she has a bunch.
Yeah.
So like that's,
that seems like a real common sense thing to do.
And that's like the most basic example I can think of off the top of my head.
Like,
okay,
so that,
that would be a good thing to train a kid to do.
Hey,
if you see someone that needs some help,
you give him some help,
especially in elderly person that's having some trouble.
That's what you do.
Yeah.
It seems real obvious.
But what I'm saying and,
and I think even,
I think most people,
most kids would be like,
oh yeah,
they'd see that.
And they would tend to go,
okay,
I'll help out.
But because most people would tend to do that,
we think we don't need to teach them.
And that's where we're losing it.
Yeah.
Like because the people on the fringes,
they're not helping that person.
There's someone on the fringe that's going to like,
oh,
they dropped it back and we'll steal it from him.
Right.
So that's where we end up with a problem.
Yeah.
Yeah,
that's true.
And that's why these things probably need to come up as part of a conversation
as a,
as like a national or universal conversations to be had of like,
okay,
what is right and wrong?
Who's given those guidances now?
Yeah.
Where are they coming from?
[inaudible] people.
Three people aren't reading the Bible anymore to look for their guidance.
They're not following Buddhism to
get their guidance from,
right.
They're just,
they're just kind of going around.
Yeah.
So where's that coming from?
Yeah,
that's true.
They're going like going around and they're seeing like,
what?
Okay.
They're looking around me like,
okay,
what are we doing?
How are we doing this?
Is this right?
Is this wrong now?
And you do.
And what are they looking at to get to measure to,
to establish that from,
you know what they're looking at Instagram.
Yeah.
Whatever's around,
whatever's around,
but Instagram's around me,
youtube around them.
That's what's around them,
and they're looking at it going,
okay,
well this is,
you know,
that seems like that's what we're doing.
All right,
cool.
That's what we're doing.
Yeah.
It's okay to soccer punched this.
You know this,
this old dude.
Yeah.
You know,
I,
you know,
I feel a little uncomfortable about it,
but you know what seems normal?
People are doing it.
Fun.
Yeah.
Laughing.
It got a lot of use.
Yeah.
So maybe that's what's cool.
That's where we need to watch out for,
and obviously I know that's an extreme case,
but really that that's true.
Where especially,
okay in these extreme cases will happen.
By the way,
if you don't have any other presence of influence,
for sure.
You know how I'm like,
oh,
I was kind of saying this.
I thought it made sense where Kate,
your kids or whatever,
they're going to learn how to behave.
Whether they learn it from you or your neighbor or the TV or the guy at the club
or the guy at the park,
whatever that part is up to you.
Like if you don't want to be there,
they're going to learn it from somebody else kind of thing.
So that idea where,
okay,
what do we,
you know,
this is a society like,
okay,
what are we doing that,
how are we doing this?
What's right?
What's wrong?
Is this wrong now?
Whatever that we're going to get that does.
Like I said,
like we're looking around,
we're trying to see what up,
you know,
and if there's no specific things,
sane or Courtney court necessarily a course,
even though of course it'd be cool if there's nothing present there to
demonstrate it,
then they're going to be like,
all right,
well what is here to demonstrate it?
And what I'm saying is we've gotten away from things that in the past would have
guided us,
at least someone,
and we'll,
you'd had this sort of sort of fundamental universal understanding of like,
thou shalt not kill.
Right?
Sure.
Well,
okay,
that,
that's a biblical thing.
And well,
you know,
maybe when a kid is 15 years old and he's feeling angry about something and he's
thinking,
you know what,
I play a video game all day where I shoot like people in this video game and
that makes me feel better.
Well,
maybe it may make me feel better to go out and do that in a school.
Right.
That's,
that's,
that's what happens.
Yeah.
So if we don't have,
if we don't lay out these things for people,
even though most people don't need them,
there are some people that need them.
That's my point,
is that we've gotten to a point where we think,
you know what?
Pretty much everyone kind of gets it.
And if everyone kind of gets it,
I don't need to emphasize it that much.
Yeah.
And so I'm not going to emphasize it.
Well,
there's some people that need it.
Yeah.
And even if you don't quote unquote need,
it's kind of like exercising,
you know,
I'm in great shape.
I don't got exercise will yet.
You kind of do,
you know?
Yeah.
It's a interesting
times.
Yeah.
This is interesting.
Speaking of interesting,
instructive talks on morals presented in the classroom often become abstract or
involve stories if people from the distant past.
So they're not likely to inspire the listener,
but moral lessons that can be acquired through judo is Randori are based on
facts and are much more likely to make an impression.
And it can be said that the habit of observation,
the ability to make decisions quickly and the ability to remain calm and
resolute that are cultivated through fighting are also valuable outcomes of the
practice of judo.
These abilities,
however,
will not be developed merely by doing catia and Randori training without any
thought.
These abilities will naturally develop when one takes care and fought and
practicing them on a daily basis.
So this is,
this is something very interesting thing about.
So I thought that was great.
Like,
Hey,
you learn about some,
you know,
you,
you read the Bible,
I,
you know,
it's like,
oh,
that doesn't really make sense to me.
It's some guy that lived thousands of years ago and well,
I don't really get that.
I don't really get why I should be humble because it says you should be humble.
We'll get on the mat now you get humbled and you feel,
you get humbled.
Right?
So there's that.
That's,
that's like the perfect example of how hey,
what you learn on the mat
is,
is truly understood.
But if you don't get exp,
if no one,
if no,
if you don't think about the fact that hey,
that reflects life too,
by the way,
that reflects life,
if no one makes that connection for you,
that's problematic.
And I mean,
clearly a Jujitsu,
this is a big difference between Jujitsu and judo.
Like we talked about what the competitions are like.
Can you talk about how you get disqualified Jujitsu?
You have people in Jujitsu that have bad attitudes,
right?
And they don't,
they don't apply what they learn in Jujitsu.
One of the things that,
you know,
my attitude always is with Jujitsu is like if I get,
if I beat someone in Jujitsu,
if you,
if you understand Jujitsu,
if you beat someone in Jujitsu,
you realize that doesn't make you a better person than the person that you beat.
What it means is you've trained more than them.
That's what it means.
Or it means you caught him that time means you got lucky with a move.
I mean,
they made a mistake and you had trained enough to be able to capitalize on it.
It doesn't mean you're a better human being than they are.
And they're,
there are people in Jujitsu that think,
oh,
I am a better human being than that person's cause I've tapped them out.
It's like actually no,
not true at all.
So if you're not connecting these bigger,
broader lessons and connecting Jujitsu to life than what you have is just,
just this isolated sport,
which,
which is,
uh,
it's not even a sport.
It's an,
it's an isolated might,
makes right attitude on the map,
which is not a good thing.
It's not a good thing.
At all.
Jujitsu should be making you humble because you should recognize like,
Oh yeah,
well I've been training longer than this guy and that's why I can beat him.
And one day if they keep training more than me,
they'll be able to beat me.
So hopefully I'll keep training and,
and we'll have a relationship and we'll be able to support each other.
And that's the attitude.
So I think that's one of the things where you know,
you've got,
in my mind you've got judo on one side,
which is really strict and controlled and,
and less evolutionary cause it doesn't evolve as much and you have Jujitsu on
the other hand,
which is wildly evolutionary,
it's incredibly creative.
Like there's,
there's less creativity in judo.
There's way more creativity in Jujitsu.
And I think in the middle,
especially on the attitude part is where Jujitsu now is like you need to like
you go to Jujitsu competition,
like little kids that are,
they have their bad sports right there,
bad sports,
they did not learn sportsmanship.
And that's an important thing because what a sportsmanship mean.
Sportsmanship doesn't just mean like you're a good sport on the mat.
No.
It means that in life you can handle getting beaten and you're going to get back
up and you're going to have a good attitude.
That's what sportsmanship is.
That's why you're trying to teach that to your kids.
Right.
And there's a million little things like that and Jujitsu that you learned,
like just the hard training.
Well you,
you know what,
in Jujitsu sometimes you work hard and you still get beat.
Yeah.
That's the way life is.
Yes sir.
You work hard,
you put give it everything you got and you still gonna get beat.
Well guess what do you learn from that?
You learn about life from that,
you know,
the creativity part.
If you're stuck in a box on something and,
and he talked about that earlier,
like,
oh yeah.
When he's talking about there's only one path.
Again,
I talk about him as being a very,
uh,
I won't see,
not creative,
but he's,
he's got an orderly brain.
Right.
Cause I never look at something that's there's one path.
Yeah.
Like,
and by the way,
if I fail in business,
he's like,
hey,
there's only one path.
Know if I fail in business,
I'm actually going to look and see like,
well,
okay,
what other path could I take?
Now he's talking about the path of like,
like I'm not saying Hell No,
the hell with discipline and I'm just gonna do whatever I want.
So he's staying stay on that path and that makes sense.
But there is a certain lack of creativity.
They're like,
okay,
well if I make a mistake,
I'm going to assess.
I don't want to see what I can do differently.
And again,
I'm not arguing that that's that he was saying,
no,
don't ever try anything else.
But that is an important piece that you learned from Jujitsu.
Like,
Oh,
if I can't pass the guard,
this person's guard this particular way,
I need to take a different approach.
You learn that from Jujitsu and you can apply it to life.
So all of these lessons that if you don't pay attention to what you're learning
in Jujitsu and you don't reflect on it and put it back on your life,
well then all you're learning is how to fight people and beat him up.
Or then Jujitsu is not doing what it should.
It's not doing what it could be doing for you.
Yeah.
So you need to be careful of that.
I think his thing,
his one path is it's this really broad and general kind of dirt.
It's more of a direction than it is.
It is.
And I,
that's a bad example for me to use.
Um,
but at the same time,
I want to make sure people aren't like,
well,
you know,
I'm going to stay on the path.
I'm going to stay the course,
stay the course.
You know what,
we failed at time,
but it's okay.
I'm going to stay the course and to keep going.
No,
no,
no.
I'll assess,
see what you can do differently.
All right.
Um,
effective use of mental and physical energy.
Again,
he's,
he's talking about this Si Sikiru Zinio an integral,
which is integral to the teachings of judo.
Competition can be applied to many aspects of life.
Those who practiced judo must measure their behavior by this principle on a
daily basis and make corrections when appropriate.
If you actually apply this standard to every aspect of your life from food,
clothing,
and shelter to your work in relationships,
you'll find that you often have to correct your own mistakes.
Those who do this,
we'll make progress day by day and advanced in life.
Those who fail to do so will never progress and in many cases will regress.
So keep an eye on those little things.
Yeah.
With regard to memory,
in the early stages of practices of judo,
you must do what you have been taught in order to do this.
You must remember thinking as well as practice progresses,
you must eat.
You must remember not only what you have been taught,
but also what you have observed.
So there are many situations in which memory is vital.
You will develop that ability naturally to come up with ways to remember things
he's talking about.
Some of the benefits of learning judo.
So one of us,
you learn to remember things next week,
come to the area of imagination.
This is not particularly necessary during the early stages of the practice of
judo,
but becomes quite necessary later.
You may experience experiment with various outcomes,
carefully anticipating how your opponent will react,
but if there is a limit to the ideas you can come up with and if the range is
narrow,
no good ideas will come to you no matter how much time passes.
On the other hand,
if you come up with a variety of ideas one after another,
and if your thoughts extend to things quite different from your original idea,
you can come up with a perfect solution among those ideas.
So he talks about creativity
and this is interesting.
Next couple language.
This is very important to the practice of judo.
The reason is it is the reason is that in Randori as well as in Catia,
if you try and explain a particular method in words,
unless you explain it exceptionally logically and clearly,
your listener will not understand what you mean.
There are some things that can be demonstrated in detail using Catia while
others do not lend themselves to this method.
In some cases you must explain things in writing or verbally when teaching,
whether you demonstrate things through Catia only or by giving a verbal
explanation while demonstrating the Kata makes a big difference to the listener.
This is a truism when you ask something,
when you ask someone about something you do not understand or discuss something
in depth,
it is beneficial.
If you could talk about it clearly Voss it is.
So in the practice of judo,
take care of,
take care to discuss things logically and clearly.
So even he talks about the importance of being able to express yourself and
having good command of the language.
It applies to judo.
Is that reaching maybe a little bit,
but we'll give it to him.
I'm gonna give it to the,
yeah,
no,
yeah.
The way I see it as like,
you know,
the what is the laws of combat?
Simple,
right?
Yeah.
That's,
that's what simple.
Clear.
Concise.
Yeah,
for sure.
you're right.
Good call.
I like it.
Next.
I would like to discuss the need for broad mindedness.
Broad mindedness means open to new ideas as well as the ability to organize
various kinds of ideas at the same time without mixing them up.
The reason this is important to the practice of judo is that when there is no
broad mindedness,
people often become overly confident in their own beliefs such that if there are
new ideas that are superior,
not only do they not accept these new ideas,
but in doing so,
they failed to determine their value and whether they are good or bad.
This is something you see all the time with people with ego.
It closed mind.
They don't listen to anybody else.
They don't come up with any new ideas.
It's
horrible.
So keep an open mind my way or the highway or is that a different thing?
You don't want none of that.
None of the highway.
Yeah.
Okay.
Speaking of simple,
the theory of judo fighting includes some quite complicated ideas.
When we consider the relationship between the body and the four limbs,
their positions,
how to use them,
how to handle the mental aspects.
One theory gets mixed up with many others,
so it becomes difficult to reach an overall conclusion.
Even if we link these complicated theories to look at them separately,
the ability to unify them in the end must be the second requirement for broad
mindedness.
Going to be able to connect things.
You gotta be able to simplify things.
This is interesting.
There is a teaching in judo competition that says one must look at the
relationship between oneself and others and one's surroundings.
So you have to Orient is,
is this his Ooda loop?
Yeah,
the loop.
So you have to,
you have to orient yourself to what's happening.
You have to look around and see what's going on.
Okay.
Another one in judo fighting.
There is a teaching Saki,
oh Torah,
which means anticipate.
Simply put,
this means using your Waza on your opponent before he can use his Waza on you.
Boom.
Be Aggressive.
Default aggressive.
Don't wait for the enemy to do something you do.
At first
there is another teaching in judo fighting your Cuto Danko and this translates
to decisive action after careful consideration.
Do Keto means carefully considering the situation before attempting to use a
Waza.
DANCO means acting without delay.
Once you have made a decision,
when this teaching is applied to the path people take in life,
it can indeed be relevant in many situations.
This is a good one.
What do you consider what you're gonna do?
But then once you make a decision,
you go,
yeah,
you go full speed,
you go full speed.
You always reassess.
You always keep your mind open.
Even when I'm like,
I made a section like,
hey,
are you know what?
We've debated this enough.
Let's go.
Even when I say that and I'm meeting,
I'm still just making sure.
I always make sure I'm always reassessing.
Yeah,
and they run to my death.
It seems like he's more talking about like,
don't,
don't make a decision.
Go and then hesitate the whole time.
That's definitely true.
And also don't sit there and wait to make a decision.
Make a decision.
But this is what's interesting here is that here's a conscience back to the book
of further teaching,
which seems to be somewhat contrary.
Contradictory to Danco is known as toe tomorrow to Koro or Sheider and that
translates know when to stop.
This means that when you venture to use a Waza up to a certain point,
but when you reach that point you might stop again.
This rule has universal applicant applicability to many aspects of life as well.
So there you go.
You got those two opposing forces.
One is like go and the other one's like no,
wouldn't to stop.
Yeah,
so those are,
let's just say very important.
One of the most important concepts in judo fighting says if you win,
do not boast of your victory.
If you lose,
do not be discouraged when it is safe.
Do not be careless.
When it is dangerous,
do not fear simply continued down the path ahead.
Okay.
Right.
Those are normal face,
normal face.
Yes.
Affirmative.
When encountering social pressures such as those such as those we experienced
today,
even an incredibly strong willed person can lose spirit and experience great
adversity.
This is when we must,
this is when he must show true character at times like these.
The ability to overcome difficulties in Durham,
be patient preserved ones honor and maintain a spirit of integrity are truly
valuable above all else.
In order to do this first,
you must develop good daily habits.
Hmm.
These good habits include simplicity and moderation.
And while thinking of yourself,
always keep other people and society as a whole in mind as well.
You must not trouble others for your own convenience.
And if you can,
you must try to benefit others while benefiting yourself.
In other words,
you must protect yourself and contribute to society,
which is the ultimate purpose of the study of judo
and judo is a lot bigger than you thought it was,
is.
Yes,
it is.
Yes sir.
He's trying to take it to the distance.
Well,
those who want to do something to benefit society must first make sure they can
easily take care of their own business.
Yeah,
you clean your room.
Yeah.
As Jordan says,
take care of your own business.
Know then you can worry about the rest of society,
like the Oxygen Mask,
right?
You gotta you gotta put it on yourself first,
then you put it on,
you can handle your kids.
If you're suffocating,
how are you going to help your kid?
You're not,
you can't hear.
We get a little controversy.
Professional wrestlers and boxers are generally people have low character.
Uh,
I dunno if I can say,
oh definitely don't sign on with that.
And no matter how superior their skills,
they are mostly looked down on by society.
I guess we'd have to do some research as to what the boxers and wrestlers were
like back in his time in Japan.
Some Code Acom members have gained popularity,
popularity,
performing on tour with them.
But I don't believe this behavior is too,
is in accord with the aim of judo.
True judo practitioners must not be performers.
So that's there.
He's going to write that.
Explained to the that he wouldn't like Mcgregor.
No,
no,
no.
Down upon for sure.
Mcgregor don't care.
No.
All right.
And this is,
this is again,
I,
I had to call these things out because obviously I don't agree with Bob
wrestlers and boxers being people with low character.
In fact,
I believe the opposite of that.
But here's a good one.
In the future,
when asked to compete against wrestlers or boxers,
the competitors must decide whether the judo practitioners will complete under
the rules of boxing arrest,
wrestling,
or whether the opponent will compete under the rules of judo.
However,
those contest must never be commercialized.
They must be merely trials between volunteers for the purpose of research.
If for some reason showman should get involved,
people get charged admission and it becomes a spectator sport,
you must recognize that this is in complete violation of the spirit of Kodokan
judo.
So what about Olympic judo then?
That's,
that's a violation.
Yeah.
I mean,
there's a lot of things you call,
but actually,
you know,
judo,
gene Lavelle,
he fought,
he fought against a boxer.
My low savage,
and I think it was Denver,
I forget where it was,
but yeah,
that was like,
that's kind of noted as sort of the beginning of like whatever popular MMA,
right?
Boxer versus judoka and judo gene.
The bell is a American,
um,
icon.
He's an icon of grappling.
If you don't know who Judith Jean Labella is,
look him up.
He's awesome.
And he actually,
so he did this back in the day back in 1963 what do you think the outcome was?
Boxer versus judo in a fight fight.
They fought.
They fought like in an MMA fight.
I mean it was,
it was,
you fight each other.
Let's gene labelle then.
Yeah.
That's doing the bell all day,
right?
Yeah.
Take down rear naked choke.
That's what he got.
Yeah.
That's how it went.
So yeah,
that's,
you know,
it's just interesting how completely commercialized.
Yeah,
this is,
and it's also interesting that again,
close mindedness or I don't know if you'd call it closed mindedness,
but he,
he has a very orderly brain.
Yeah.
And he was like,
look,
it's either going to be those rules or these roles.
He didn't think to himself like,
Hey,
you know what?
What if you just mix it up and do it all together?
All rules.
Why wouldn't we do that?
Which is interesting because in judo they do cover striking and you don't hear
about it much,
but they have,
those are part of it.
Hmm.
So it's interesting that in his mind he's like,
no,
it's either of those rules for these roles.
Fairly rigid,
very rigid thinker.
Yeah.
That's a good point.
Back to the book into everyday Randori practice,
fighting against another person is not the real purpose of the practice of judo,
because fighting to see who will win is interesting.
It is done on a daily basis.
Yes,
it is.
It goes without saying that becoming able to beat someone is one of the ultimate
goals of the practice of Randori.
However,
there's clearly a difference between becoming able to beat someone at a future
time and becoming obsessed at beating someone now.
Hmm.
In order to beat someone now,
it is best for those who are strong to use that strength to overcome the other
person's strength.
However,
with that method,
if you encounter opponent who is much stronger than you are,
you will naturally lose.
So even if you lose for a while,
the correct practice of Rent Dory is to slip dexterously away from your
opponent,
adapt to his strength,
caused him to lose his balance while stepping back and then take advantage of
the opportunity to perform a Waza.
If you do this kind of training,
you will for a while,
often be twisted by the arm and held down or pushed down by your opponent.
But if you do not frequently engage in this kind of training,
you will never learn how to beat a stronger in Ponant.
So this is what we talk about all the time when we talk about relaxing and
trying to relax and
putting yourself in bad positions and not using your strength.
That's what we're talking about.
And again,
that applies to life as well.
That applies to
not staying in your comfort zone,
not continuing to concentrate on what you're good at.
Focus on your weaknesses.
That's what that talks about.
That's interesting.
His how he said don't,
don't be focused on beating the other guy.
You know,
it's almost like holding or talked about that real briefly when I first met him,
where he was like,
like,
it's not like you're not looking how big the guy is,
how tough he,
what belty
has and all this stuff.
It's like you're focusing on,
on your Jujitsu,
what's lacking,
what I know and don't know.
You know,
if I'm focusing on the other guy and I'm going to beat him and all this stuff,
that's not what,
what the Jujitsu is.
Yeah.
And
I'll go ahead and say this like this is,
this sounds good,
but we all,
I mean at least every single person I trained with,
like we're trying to,
we're trying to win a voucher.
That being said,
now of the,
actually I'm going to go in and correct myself,
like we train,
we want to win,
but like you take way more risks training with our,
with our training team.
Then you would take,
if you were training with someone else.
Yeah.
Right.
You take it,
you know,
you take rescue,
try new things.
You put yourself in bad positions.
I'm going to try this.
I'm gonna try this arm lock.
I'm gonna try this choke even though I might end up on the bottom.
But that's okay.
Well,
you know what I mean?
So I guess that's true.
I don't focus completely on just trying to beat the other person.
Yeah.
So that's,
that's actually very accurate.
And I think as you are,
as you start this game,
that's the best attitude to have is like,
hey,
you got to relax.
And I was talking to a buddy of mine that's just starting Jujitsu out and he's
like my age and yeah,
he's like,
man,
I'm trying to relax harder.
She's like,
And actually what I teach I,
I sent him a text and I was like,
it's like rock climbing.
Have you ever done any rock climbing before?
Yes.
So there's technique in rock climbing.
Like there's legit technique obviously.
Well it's not obvious if you,
if you've never rock climbed before,
there's a massive amount of technique and rock climbing.
It's the way you position your fingers to way position your hands,
the way you use your legs.
You,
you don't hang the weight on your muscles and you hang it on your,
your bones and your ligaments so you're not getting tired.
Your muscles aren't getting tired out because you're using the technique.
If you don't know rock climbing,
guess what you do.
You hang on to the freaking rock with all your muscle and as long as you can.
And that's exactly what happens in Jujitsu when your technique is good,
you're just going to hang on.
Yeah,
hang on.
That he,
the whole thing about do,
you just didn't winning and he and he used the word obsessed like little bit of
a different scenario.
And really when you really look at it,
I mean in the moment,
yeah,
you want to beat the guy like that.
That's when you train with someone in Jujitsu or especially when you compete in
Jiu Jitsu.
That's actually where the shift kinda occurs.
He mentioned competition as not a spectator sport.
This is just for experimental purposes or did he research research and research
purposes,
which is essentially just training really.
So say sure.
It's kind of like,
um,
kind of how when they started the first of UFC that was what they are kind of
pushing to.
They're like,
we're going to see how,
what martial art style exactly right.
And,
but really,
you know the,
the thing that people came to see was that for sure,
but it was a show like who's going to win and all this stuff and when you really
look at it,
so you'll see one,
two,
all these things.
It was,
I don't want to say rare,
but it was almost rare when,
aside from hoists,
Gracie of course,
and you Ken shamrock and stuff like this,
it was really rare to see the style get maintained.
It was like these crazy guys and they had their stents and the fight with cross
street fight.
Yeah,
exactly right.
So,
and that was part of the research kind of kind of thing.
But you know,
people were there to see who's going to kick his ass.
But in Jiu Jitsu when you really,
when you really think about it,
we are kind of maintaining that.
Like we want to say like we're,
we're researching all the time.
Yeah.
And use and you can,
you can fall back and forth.
Like sometimes you can get sucked into being obsessed with beating that guy and
maybe if you kind of use it,
you know,
it's like using anger to help you,
I don't know,
get more strength of something just for a moment or whatever they,
I,
I kind of think that's okay.
And I think we all kind of do it in one way or another.
Not the anger thing necessarily,
but that I'm going to like me and you,
for example,
I might incorporate a little bit today,
so I'm going to get Jocko today.
That's what I'm kind of focused on for a second.
Yeah,
yeah.
For a second to help me get better.
Maybe even give me pass a mental barrier or something like that and you know,
you can do it,
but the big picture is just what he's talking about.
I just want to get better at my job to kind of thing.
I will say this too.
I Ego wise,
I think it's very positive to be like,
yeah,
I don't want to lose and,
and the only way you're not going to lose is to train all the time.
Yeah.
So the days,
the days that you're like,
well,
you know,
I don't,
like yesterday I was on a different time zone came back.
It was,
I got back in the day.
I had work to do.
As soon as I hit the ground,
I got done with that.
I hit a quick workout and now it's like,
oh,
it's guess what time it is.
Just through time.
And I'm like,
well,
you know,
I was like,
oh well,
you know,
maybe it's been a long day.
My shoulder kind of hurts right now,
so maybe I'll just,
you know,
breath.
Then I was like,
no,
can we go to train?
Because,
because what I know is not training,
this is not training.
One day might not make a difference,
but that one day does make a difference.
You might not,
you might tell yourself it doesn't make a difference,
but there's,
there's something in there.
It was every day of training you can get matters.
Everyday counts.
You can't get it back and if you miss it,
you miss it.
Especially like right now,
I've been traveling a lot lately,
weigh more than normal,
so I know like if I got to get there,
you want to get my rounds in gotta get my rounds it.
That's the way it's got to be.
And part of that is my ego,
but others,
my ego saying,
look,
I gotta I got to fight,
I got to struggle to be stay on top.
We've got to stay on top of the mountain as high as I can.
Hungry young bucks are out there.
They're coming after me.
Yes,
I appreciate that.
But that keeps me in check my ego.
The positive part of ego is that I do.
I do want to win and I don't want to get beat.
Now that being said,
guess who I trained with?
I trained with all the guys that are most likely to beat me.
That's what I want.
I want to have that happen.
So there's a balance.
There's a good balance there.
And at the end of the,
there's really no
escape it.
And I think it's real prevalent like for you and dean and the,
it's really prevalent where sure you have all that,
you have all those thoughts,
you know,
in your head or whatever.
But it all comes to the whole reason you have that thought is to get better at
at judiciary for sure.
It's,
yeah,
cause when you start Jujitsu you like,
some people see me like,
well you know,
I'll just,
I just want to get good enough to like,
you know,
be able to defend myself.
Well,
after six months,
man,
you're good.
So what am I doing here?
25 years later,
we're still during the same there.
Cause like there's a couple of guys that I,
well I,
you know,
I want to keep ahead of or even with or catch,
like that's what's driving this.
So there's,
there's a definite ego thing involved.
Uh,
but
I think the,
where that goes too far,
the ego goes too far.
This is obvious answer is like,
oh,
I don't really,
you don't want me to,
I'm not going to train with that guy cause he might catch me right then.
Now you're not,
you're not progressing.
Now you're in this thing that he's talking about.
Like you're not going to progress because you're not going to train with that
person or you're not going to take any risks whatsoever.
So you're just going to defend,
defend,
and you like,
oh,
I survived the round and I'm out of here.
Yeah.
So you gotta,
you gotta keep that attitude of like,
Hey,
I'm going to get beat.
And you know,
that's a thing.
Jiu Jitsu works,
man.
Yeah.
Did you do it works.
And if somebody catches you,
doesn't matter who they are,
if they catch you,
Jujitsu works your tap out,
you go again.
That's the beautiful thing about Jujitsu.
That's the beautiful thing about life.
Because in life,
you're not going to win every time you're going to call it.
You're gonna make mistakes.
Someone's going to capitalize on them.
So what are you going to do?
You're going to give up.
And even more important than that you can lose,
you can lose is whatever thing you're trying to do,
you can lose your trying to start a new business.
You can lose your trying to get a new job,
you can lose,
you can lose in life.
So are you going to prevent that from even getting let that prevent you from
even getting on the mat in the first place?
Aren't even trying to start a new business.
Even trying to,
trying to do something that's outside your comfort zone.
That's what this,
that's what this is saying is get outside of your comfort zone.
Don't sit there.
It's not going to help you.
Yeah,
and you can see it with,
with the guys who you can tell are just focused on like being the guy who beat
the other guy and kind of thing.
Then they'll do those kinds of things.
They'll roll and then when they,
after two,
three rounds,
when they're,
they feel their steam kind of going down.
They'll leave or they'll sit on the side and talk to me like I'm not rolling
anymore.
Or the only rule of small guys did that to Andy yesterday.
What we did like six rounds and I was like,
Brian,
he's a backup cause you know,
he's training for events.
You know,
like I,
I'm,
I'm going to give a,
I was like,
hey,
I called Doctor Luke,
I'm like,
Doctor Luke,
give me some help over here.
I need some backup.
Yeah,
yeah.
You know,
cause got to,
got to get him to step it up.
But what's interesting or what's the reality is when I have the time or when I'm
not,
when I at the time,
but like I always get my rounds to like we're doing,
if we've got two guys that are competing and we're doing two in one out,
like I put them through it and then I go through it too.
Cause I want to get my training cause I'm trying to get better too.
To your point.
Yeah.
You're
not in there trying to be dandy drinking.
I'm trying to get better.
Yeah.
And that's exactly what I mean.
And it's obvious,
you know.
Uh,
but you know,
you know,
it's a big symptom of someone who's,
who's focusing on the wrong thing is like if they don't do well or whatever,
and they say stuff like,
Oh,
you're lucky this isn't MMA or something like that.
They're like,
they're unhappy about the fact that they got by,
you know,
like I used to train with sky will remain nameless,
uh,
long time ago.
And that's what he'd always say.
Like,
Oh yeah,
if there was strikes,
I would have one kind of thing.
He'd say that kind of stuff all the time.
I was like,
Bro,
focusing on the wrong thing right now.
The fact that you quote unquote got beat or I beat you and this is how you would
have beat me.
You know,
you're focusing on the wrong thing.
Why do you think I do?
Cause I do this.
How do the opposite when I roll with someone and I'll be like,
hey,
you know,
like I'll catch him or whatever.
I'll be like,
yeah,
you know,
hey,
if this was MMA,
like let's say I'm going to their member of harder to catch them,
I'll be like,
hey,
you know,
if this is MMA,
you're on top for a while.
You'd been,
you'd have been pounded me in the face.
I would have been good.
You would have one more.
If I'm going against [inaudible] guy and to catch him or something,
I'll be like,
yeah,
you know though,
if that was points though,
you were up
like eight points,
you probably would have beat me.
And that was uh,
that took me 15 minutes to get.
So you would have won.
Yeah.
And See,
I obviously,
I don't know exactly what's going on in your head,
but it seems like that would be something you'd say to someone to make them kind
of feel better.
Cause you know,
it's a little mini competition in there for real.
I mean that's essentially what makes it so good because he's giving you an
accurate look how in a motivated opponent attack or whatever would look like
when he's going full speed again too.
So there is that element of like we're competing against each other and when you
lose this kind of like,
oh,
I lost to this guy,
especially if you're not that used to training or,
or so I'm just being nice.
You're being nice I think.
And at the same time if you're saying stuff like,
hey,
if this was MMA,
you'd be pounding me,
or something like that,
that there could be a little element of your own training.
Kind of like you're just voicing your thoughts.
I kept that in mind where,
you know,
I have got hit there and you're just kind of voicing it maybe for the benefit of
yourself as well as the guy.
I don't know that that's what it seems like.
Um,
what happened if someone was thinking those things,
check,
well,
you know,
that's,
we could go on this book for a long time.
I think that's a good place to,
um,
reflect and say,
look,
there's a lot of principles that you can apply.
Judo and Jujitsu.
There's things that Jujitsu should,
you should take from Jujitsu and things that you should take from judo
principles.
And if you mix those two together,
you start get something that's really powerful,
not just on the mat but something that's really powerful to apply to your life.
Again,
is everything in this theories?
Perfect.
No.
Somebody asked me that the other day.
I was with a group of young leaders and someone,
cause I was talking about how it's beneficial to read about history and
understand warfare and understanding.
It gives you an insight into human nature and gives you an insight into people,
the way people think and all the stuff.
And this guy says,
Hey,
do you ever think that maybe what you read was,
and if you apply what,
what was you read?
You'll actually end up making a mistake or do you just follow what you know,
history?
And I'm like,
no.
That's the whole reason I go.
Because the more you read,
the more you understand the more different angles you see.
And I'm questioning every decision I make.
I'm questioning all these things all the time and I'm using all these different
information that I have in my head as sounding boards to check off of like what
it will.
At least let me shed some light on it.
Gather some intelligence.
That's what,
that's what I'm trying to do.
So yeah,
question yourself and question these theories.
That's what I think that's one of the best things about,
it's one of the best things about MMA in Jujitsu and fighting right now is that
it's evolving so fast and,
and it's open for it.
And if you're not down for that right now,
you're going to be left in the dust.
You're going to be left in the dust.
Does this mean that every fancy new movie that comes out should be applied to
your game?
No.
It doesn't mean that at all.
Does it mean that every fancy guid Jujitsu move that you saw in worlds would be
super effective in a fist fight?
No.
It doesn't mean that at all.
But should you have an open mind to understand that some of those things could
be absolutely beneficial and yes,
you definitely should.
So keep an open mind with everything that you're doing.
You know,
that idea of broad mindedness,
sometimes I wish Canaan would've had a little bit more broad mindedness.
Yeah.
Cause that w you know,
it would have been beneficial.
You know,
that's one of the sad things about judo as they,
they outlawed the double leg take down in judo,
you can't do it.
You can do it after you've done another take down attempt.
So it can be like a follow on.
Gotcha.
But that's not cool.
That's not cool.
And it's the same thing with,
with Jujitsu,
right?
When they outlaw certain submissions like uh,
the,
the heel hook with Gi Jujitsu.
Yeah.
Right.
Like the heel hook is still there.
The heel hook itself is still there in the,
in the the motion of,
yeah,
it's there.
You shouldn't,
I'll lock it should be part of it because then you have people ending up in
positions where they're not effective fighting positions.
They're not because you can get healed,
he'll come to you,
get your knee rip torn apart.
So why would you outlaw something that's very effective?
It's,
it's,
I understand there is some danger in the heel hook for those of you that don't
know,
the danger of the heel hook is that it doesn't create pain before it creates
industry in injury.
Well,
it doesn't create a lot of pain before it creates industry in injury.
So you can fee,
you can have a heel hook on you and it can be like,
oh I can get out of this and the person starts applying pressure and you like,
oh that doesn't really hurt.
And then pop your,
get your,
you have to go get surgery.
Now that's the problem with heel hooks.
But if you and your training partners understand that and if competitors
understood like,
hey,
if I get caught here,
I'm going to end up in surgery if I don't tap.
So that's the,
if you understand that,
then you won't go in these positions that where you're exposed to heal hook.
So that's what you should do.
Not only with Jujitsu,
but you should do with life to like understand what really works.
Don't outlaw things,
don't things just because
you're not good at them.
Yeah,
open yourself up to them.
Do you know why they don't?
They really don't allow heel hooks and geek competition.
Do you know?
Why are you asking me that question now?
The reason that they say,
I think it's because the,
the possibility of injury.
Yeah.
Then no Nogi they let it lie cause you can slide more than,
I don't know.
I think that's,
I think that might be just tradition.
But hopefully,
you know,
they should allow double leg take downs and judo.
They should allow heel hooks and Jujitsu and engage you Jitsu.
Now this doesn't mean if you were all with me and we're rolling,
Gee,
you just slap a heal hook on me because I won't be expecting that and I'll be
pissed or that should be part of your training.
Yeah.
And so congratulations.
It is,
but yeah,
I guess you're right.
I need to tighten it up.
Yeah,
I would say that is one of those things.
Here's what it is with the hill with Geek,
like if someone busts,
cause it's so widely known as,
as uh,
uh,
district loud.
Yeah.
It's like if you get a guy,
especially let's say extreme scenario,
a new guy comes in,
he's a purple belt,
hungry blue belt.
He comes in,
he rolls with,
you know,
one of the instructors,
black belt or whatever it [inaudible],
you know,
they're rolling and he's going super hard and he goes for a heel hook.
Pause right there.
Technically,
the Wa as far as what we're talking about,
that should be okay.
We're all here training,
we're all getting better.
He's going hard.
Thank thanks for the good training kind of thing he did.
But we're essentially trained to see heel hooks with the is as disrespectful.
It's against the rules.
It's so embedded in,
it's like it's embedded in the culture really.
But really as far as what we're talking about,
like it's really okay,
you know?
Yeah,
he's muscle.
I'll look,
I'll say no,
that's not okay.
And the reason I'm saying that
trajectory for me because,
but this is the similar thing,
right?
If you,
if you came into the gym and like you went for,
he'll hook on me.
We were trying to g and I started punching in the face,
right?
That like,
like you weren't expecting that,
but you should be prepared for it.
So there is fires.
If you understand that that's what you're training like,
oh,
are we street rules,
punches legal allowed to what I'm saying?
There's,
there's certain things that are universally,
as far as I,
I have not been anywhere and I talked to a lot of district people and I wrote a
lot of different genes to places where it's like you're wearing a geek.
You're,
it's,
you're,
you're cleared hot to do heal hooks.
Yeah.
I have not seen that anywhere.
Me Neither.
And it should be that way.
Well,
I mean tech,
the thing is I'm with you and they,
you know,
there's exceptions of course.
And just because I happened is Craig Craig Baker will allow,
I didn't even say,
yeah,
you can heal hook.
It doesn't come up because just like you were saying,
it's so widely known and understood from the beginning.
You don't do heal hooks with the geek.
It's just,
but why is that?
We don't really think about why is that and does it.
We won't miss those are the thinker recognized sanctioned rules.
Right.
Just
like the recognized sanction rules say that if we're grappling,
I'm not going to start punching you in the face.
No,
but no,
because that's punching in the face and not grappling.
Like if he it punching in the face does deviate from when you,
when you start learning did you to,
unless it's understood that that's the kind of training you're going to get.
So here's the thing.
Okay.
When I put on the geese,
these rules,
these moves are not allowed,
right?
There's no,
I don't know.
There's no rules.
I mean,
sure Ibj JF,
but you know,
months.
This is probably bigger percentage of people that did.
You do to have never competed in IBG DF tournament.
Probably the majority,
the people,
yet we're following.
I'd be GGF rules in training sometimes.
Even though actually the geek competitions,
I've never heard of a competition that allows heel hooks even at Pacific bell.
But that's not the point.
The point isn't that they're not allowed,
so don't do them.
That's not the point.
The point is why are they not allowed?
Given what we're just talking about there,
in my opinion,
they're not allowed because of the propensity or possibility of an injury or I
people think that there's a high possibility buddy you could get injured.
They're,
they're somewhat accurate because it is a different kind of pain or it was a
lack of pain and so there's a little bit accuracy.
Yeah,
I dig it and I see if I split specially if that is true as far as why they want
it.
Because some people might say they'd want it because Jiu Jitsu was,
was always looked at as this linear thing.
Like Don,
Don,
her mentioned kind of mentioned part of this where you know,
you get past the legs and you work your way up his body to tap them out and you
can start tapping them out when you get up to the upper body and the legs were
just something you had to get past because they're going to try to kick you and
you know,
they have leverage on their own body and all this stuff and that's it.
That's traditionally how we look at Jujitsu and that's the effectiveness.
Did you just do this?
This is the best in all this stuff.
Now you get,
you know,
a new person or someone from sambal or whatever.
We'll come in and be like,
oh that's Jujitsu or let me go ahead and kind of flip it upside down a little
bit and change what this Jujitsu and they're like,
we don't like that kind of thing.
Yeah.
That could be why I'm just saying that's what it could be.
Why,
let me ask you this.
I have,
I have heard like that people's initial reaction,
I think I've heard dean say this,
like if your reaction is like,
oh that's not good for my game,
we'll just outlawed.
Yeah.
That's what it resulted in.
Cause all Jujitsu guys are training.
This was,
hey do a double leg,
take downs are not good for judo against the rest.
Or you've got someone that's been wrestling for 27 years and they come and do a
new judo competition.
They hit a double leg.
It's not good for the judo player.
Yeah.
There's two guys.
What kind of thing?
And so guess what outlaw.
Yeah.
Which is a bummer.
Right?
And so yeah,
I'm not,
I'm not pro outlawing.
It was the ultimate point there.
That's what I heard of.
So let me ask you this.
Do you think in training who hooks with the gate?
Just you personally you think they should be allowed?
He looks with
the key.
I think they should be allowed every time.
All the time.
Everywhere,
but they are not right now.
And therefore in my mentality is like okay,
because I'm not going to put myself a new position that a heel hook is available
to you unless I know that they're not available.
Exactly.
Yeah I did.
And I dig it and actually I agree that's the same thing.
Like,
like if we were going to roll and I just did it,
no good.
But if I said hey,
before we rolled like one,
we're walking there or even right before we kind of,
you know,
shook hands whenever they said,
hey,
heel hooks are a go,
that would change the game.
Yeah,
we change the game for sure.
Okay.
So,
same thing,
like if you're doing Nogi and you know guys like they just don't know or
whatever and they'll grab your shorts,
they'll grab your shirt,
rash guard or whatever,
they'll grab it,
you know,
cause they just don't know.
Even if it's the same deal,
less dangerous of course,
but same deal where it's like when you start doing that,
then they'll stop and be like,
Hey,
you can't do that kind of thing.
But if you say before you roll,
hey yeah,
you can grab shorts,
whatever up to you,
just don't pull him off or something like that.
It's kind of one of those deals you could I guess,
make some ad hoc rules before you start rolling.
But yeah,
we're just go with what's universally accepted at this time.
Slaps in the face or illegal.
Sometimes it's cool,
whatever.
All right.
Well like I said,
a lot of stuff to learn from
judo and Jujitsu to make yourself better in those sports and in life.
So good.
Yeah,
the I,
I was actually pretty,
I don't want to say impressed,
but pretty impressed with the whole book.
Yeah.
Except for the part about telling people how to eat,
telling people how to eat,
uh,
the calisthenics or no good.
Yeah.
Be In buff is a waste of time.
There's definitely some,
and I used some truth to that.
It's weird because as I'm preparing the podcast,
I'm like,
okay,
do I just say the things in here that I agree with?
Oh yeah,
yeah.
Cause that's one way I could do it.
Do I?
Because one thing that's I was thinking about when I read a quote from a book,
people do,
they kind of think like,
well I agree with that.
Like I support this unless I outwardly just reject it.
And I kind of did half of the book where I was like,
well,
you know,
I don't really talk about that because I see where he's coming from,
but that's not really my gig.
And then I got to other parts of,
I was like,
I have to talk about the fact that he thinks that this stuff is,
you know,
this is a completely different than what I think,
you know.
So,
yeah,
I guess I try to explain myself as I talk about it.
But yeah,
there's,
there's definitely some things that,
that I don't agree with.
There's some things that I don't agree with about,
about judo.
Like do you know there's things that I don't agree with about Jujitsu.
I think that's why I think there's a good mixture of the two that would be very
powerful.
We need to bring Dave camera on,
you know,
some of these other guys that have grown up in judo and are savage at Jujitsu.
Okay.
So anyway.
Cool.
Well speaking of,
you know,
getting better in Jujitsu and getting better in life.
Sure.
Any suggestions on how people could get better?
So when you get,
when you start doing Jujitsu,
okay.
And g you're going to get,
that's probably one of the one,
two,
three maybe four questions you're going to have the first four we'll kind of get
your,
get you get,
that's going to be one of them.
That's my guess.
That's my uh,
prediction.
Um,
shoot,
you can be in Jujitsu and still say,
hey gee,
should I get,
you know,
new Geek,
whatever.
Anyway.
Cause the answer origin,
you get an origin geek.
That's what you do because they are factually factually see how rigid and being
right there factually the best.
Gies they're all made in America by the way.
Different types of bees there.
They got some new stuff.
By the way,
Pete just sent me some new stuff.
It's not that new.
They're just different styles.
It's not geese.
It's what I get some sweats.
Oh,
okay.
Which happened to them.
Happened to be the most comfortable sweats in my experience.
You new stuff and he sent it to me.
Sorry Bro.
You know something must be joggers told me are and they're,
you know,
they're really good.
But nonetheless back to the geese.
Um,
yeah.
Get them@originmain.com.
That's a good one.
To support yourself.
Support this huge,
it's support life support America.
America.
Because they're made in America.
Yup.
From the dirt to this shirt,
which means a shirt that cotton that is grown in America gets turns into ag
somehow.
Pete does that part.
Isn't it?
Kind of cool to think that when you put on a g,
like there's that that back,
he came from a factory in Maine,
came from a,
from a factory in Maine that was built specifically to make Jujitsu gies and
that there's people up there,
the workers up there,
craftsman up there that are in that gate for you.
And then it gets put from Maine into a bag and sent to you.
Right?
Isn't that kind of right?
It is,
yeah.
It's not like can Ughi a Geeky have soul?
I'm going to ask you that question.
Can have soul.
We don't know the answer to that.
Metaphorically speaking,
I guess.
Yeah.
But we can make it on assessment from the outside if Ughi has soul than you'd
want that soul,
but come from Maine.
Right.
And if certain gies had souls and some geese didn't have souls,
you would for sure want to get with the soul.
Yes.
100% and if geese do indeed have souls,
which I tend to believe they do,
they could.
Then you'd want the good souls,
the American soul from man.
Yup.
Well,
if Pete starts making shoes,
you'll know that they'll have souls.
Wow.
I have made a funny nonetheless.
Or do you mean.com?
That's where you get,
I'm also in Jujitsu.
Okay.
We've got to be honest here in Jujitsu,
it's physical.
You twist your
arms,
your neck and your body not twists like injure it,
but you,
you know,
it gets some work and with work needs recovery with recovery comes
supplementation,
good supplementation,
Krill oil.
I feel like I've said the word Krill oil probably more than I've said any other
food item or dietary supplement meant in my whole life.
Good.
That's high to happy about it because of how beneficial has got it.
Got More Krill oil too,
by the way.
From Pete with the Joggers,
which are nice by the way.
Um,
also another one called joint where friends,
these are all Jocko supplements by the way.
If he didn't know Super Krill,
not just regular super chocolate Supergirl,
joint warfare,
which is another formula for joint maintenance reconstruction.
Someone said,
hey,
I got knee surgery.
Is this going to help me?
Yes.
It will help your knee recover.
Especially the meniscus situation too.
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
Okay.
Anything where,
okay,
I'm not gonna go too deep into it,
but anything involving cartilage like these that don't get a bunch of blood
flow,
they tend to degenerate over well,
everything degenerate,
but over time it's not for everyone.
No complacency,
right?
No backing off.
Nonetheless,
joint warfare.
That's a good one.
Maintained the joints and this goes for any kind of physical activity.
Your joints will thank you are you will thank your joints.
You'll think Jocko for Jocko Krill oil n joint warfare.
Also discipline,
not just regular discipline as a supplement.
Discipline's a pre mission
native enhancing because people were making stuff that helped you physically
like a pre workout and then they were making nootropics.
I would help you mentally like your cognition and well in my job,
especially my old job,
guess what?
I needed both.
I needed to be mentally sharp and I needed to be physically sharp.
Yeah,
so I wanted everything in the same like mix.
Sure blend.
That's why she made the discipline and you didn't want to do the pre work on and
then boom.
And then,
okay,
let me go ahead and take the other one right here.
Okay.
The home and then you know you went to get them both.
Get them both one time.
One hit,
one win and you feel it and it feels good.
Yeah.
That's what yesterday I was talking about the rounds I did,
cause I knew I was coming at us.
I was going to pay the man so I just hit the discipline.
Yeah,
yeah.
Tastes good too by the way.
It tastes amazingly good.
What's interesting about it is cause that's monk fruit.
Yeah,
it's monk fruit.
You know what about monk fruit?
No.
Monk Fruit is the sweetener that's used in discipline.
It's like whatever,
87,000 times sweeter than sugar,
but it's just all they do put a little bit in the,
only a little tiny bit in there.
Low glycemic index.
Slow on,
let Lacey low on the glycemic index so it doesn't give you the insulin spike
and we'll just say that's good.
Just so people know there's caffeine in it,
but there's only 15 milligrams of caffeine,
so you're not going to get jittery,
but you get a little,
a little micro dose of gets a little help,
a little little catalog,
but monkfruit also they like helps an eight.
It's,
it's legit.
Yeah.
Other thoughts on that one?
It's called discipline.
Tastes good because Jack wants it to taste good.
Yeah.
That kind of freaked you out.
He had threw me off for sure.
He thought maybe I just want things to taste horrible so it takes more
discipline to drinking a black and white like that.
I was like,
hmm.
Interesting that that was part of the focus,
but hey,
good.
I say good.
Well you're going to be really happy that I have this attitude when the,
when the protein comes out.
Sure.
Yeah.
The mint chocolate chip,
you know,
um,
just Fyi,
it's not normal and it's got the monk crude in it,
so that's the sweetener.
So it tastes delish and it doesn't taste like anything else.
There's no way that it could taste this good and,
and be what it is.
Gotcha.
Yeah.
Sorry,
I just made up.
I had to make up my own name for it.
Yeah,
yeah,
it dig it.
You did the right thing.
Do the right thing.
It's called a Moke,
m o l k with the UHMM lot over the,
Oh,
you know why tribute to Motorhead layers.
Layers.
Good man.
I think that's good.
So yeah,
pretty soon people are going to be on the mole.
Quinn is that a couple of weeks?
We've got it.
We went through the final testing.
It's so,
it's so,
it tastes good.
It's easy to digest,
easy,
all the good things and they still remember back in the diversity.
It's more
kind of sounds like I need,
this is like,
I don't even know what to say.
This isn't,
it's not like a chocolate milkshake.
It's not like a protein shake.
It's like,
it's like,
it's like milk
mega mass.
I think it was 5,000 and three million five thousand five thousand probably.
No,
it was 0002000500 it might've been.
Okay.
I think that was that South Park.
That was 5,000 right?
Double Super Colostrum,
seven fever phrase we used to make fun of us.
Nonetheless.
It was super delicious.
It was like a big like dog food bag full of mega mass.
What?
500 or whatever it was,
chocolate.
You drink it and it tastes straight up like a chocolate milkshake and guess
what?
It probably was just going to say that's the thing that's easy.
All kind of like quote health foods nowadays they're like,
oh,
this is pro.
You look at the look of the thing on a protein bar and then compare the protein
bar to a snickers bar and it's like the same content inside of it.
Whatever.
Yes.
Be careful.
I saw a hell.
That's what was cool about discovering the monk fruit is being able to make
stuff tastes really without having the crap
artificial sweeteners in it.
Yeah.
In a way that's kind of going back to your roots,
right?
Where where it's like,
okay,
we got sweetness.
Sweetness is a thing.
It's a natural thing.
We'd like it,
you know,
for a reason.
All of this stuff,
cool man.
Don't do away with the sweetness,
but you know when you start engineering foods to like to,
to kind of like the advertising I was talking about,
maybe I should come up with something that just tastes horrible and you just
have to gut check to taste it.
Just to test yourself mentally.
Yeah.
See how good that does.
Man,
I'm sure everyone will get this.
Really.
Yeah.
The mall.
Who made that word up?
You Oh yeah.
Motor.
Yeah.
Gotcha.
Nonetheless,
that's going to be available if the milk is going to be available in a few weeks
apparently.
Yeah.
Uh,
for the joint work for and Super Krill and this is a good idea,
by the way,
do the subscription,
they're recurring where it gets so you don't gotta remember you can get down to
your last three pills cause you don't know if you have like six pills.
That's two days.
In my case,
I don't know how many you take,
but I mean I know how many you take,
but I don't know how many other people take.
You get six fields in there.
You don't know how many pills in there.
You get one pill.
Okay.
I know there's only one by that time too late,
even six bills.
Technically it's almost too late.
Pretty much he goes subscription.
Don't worry about that stuff.
Boom.
Get the subscription.
I'm also,
like we said,
Geez,
rash guards,
compression gear,
joggers,
most comfortable ones in the world.
In my experience.
I don't know.
Maybe there's a more comfortable one.
Maybe not.
If there is,
I've never seen it through the charters.
Have a soul.
Probably not like it.
They touched your soul.
That's important.
The comfort in it for sure.
A hundred percent hundred percent origin,
main.com good way to support.
Also in Maine,
the Jujitsu immersion camp,
immerse yourself in Jujitsu for half a week.
Write half a week and a half a week cause there's like two sessions.
Can you do both sessions?
Yes,
you can.
I mean,
is that like a thing?
Of course,
yeah.
Okay,
so this is an option for that boom.
One Week.
Immersion into Jujitsu.
Just learning.
You know,
it's not like bootcamp where it like,
you know,
you're going to be forced to do a bunch of calisthenics,
which we don't advocate apparently anymore,
but we still,
we still advocate counselor.
I had to keep cows,
especially like a burpee situation,
which I think is advocate all kinds of cows.
All Cal Sachs.
Actually you can't show me a calisthenic that I don't advocate.
Even though people like are like suit ups are no good.
They work your psoas muscle,
they don't even work.
No,
I advocate them too.
I like strong PSOAS muscles.
Yeah.
Good.
Show me.
They're like,
well,
they're just need to work.
Your abs works your psoas muscle muscles like,
cool.
I'm strong.
PSOAS muscles.
Next question.
First off.
Yes,
they do work at ABS.
Trey,
don't do sit ups for one year.
Do all your other stuff and then do five sets of burnout.
Sit ups and then see if your abs are so in the next day.
Don't see it that it doesn't sit up till failure.
Oh,
okay.
That's a burn.
Can you even do sit out sit ups to failure?
Oh yeah.
It's hard and it's going to burn how much time you got to have.
You have the whole day.
Here's the,
okay.
The point isn't how
many sit ups you can do or don't.
Can't do.
The point is people saying sit ups don't do your ab muscles hip flexor and so
they do that too,
but they do have muscles nonetheless.
I agree with you.
Do you do jumping jacks?
Yeah,
I do.
Jumping Jacks to,
actually I did jumping jacks last week.
It was part of a metcon,
but still there was an old old team guy workout or
jumping jacks.
Pullups are sorry,
jumping jacks pushups and just do jumping jacks and push ups and you think it's
no big deal and then like your 45 minutes into it,
you're like,
I hate jumping jacks and push ups.
Yeah.
I don't know if I'd ever do something continuously for 45 minutes.
Well that will be the first half of that workout.
That's stupid.
Yeah.
That one would get,
especially after getting to get any exercise and you can make it soc after 45
minutes.
Yeah.
Like there's,
I can't even think of an exercise.
It doesn't suck after 45 but you're just doing buds,
neck rotations.
Just do that in the teams too.
You're just laying down.
You're like,
okay,
I'm just gonna lay down and move my head around.
Oh,
laying down here.
I never even laid down neck rotations one to do that for 45 minutes.
You're like,
this is the dumbest thing I've ever done in my life,
but I'm glad we're doing it.
Yeah.
I think you're right about that.
Well,
I figured that key would be,
if you don't like the whole 45 minutes thing is you do something that's hard
enough of a movement that you don't have to do 45 minutes.
Yeah,
that's,
that's good.
If you don't want to just do something that sucks for 45 minutes.
I did a metcon,
like just kind of representative of what you were talking about earlier where it
was,
um,
it was like how many of this,
these two movements you can do within a certain amount of time,
which was different.
Usually I set my rest time to a certain time and I do.
I'm in boom and yeah,
that was a good,
good little change up.
Yeah,
do that.
Or you can do jumping jacks and pull ups for 45 minutes at a time when you
wouldn't even have pull up bars.
So we're like straight up in the ship or something.
Jumping Jacks,
pushups.
Everyone just goes,
oh God.
Pouring workup.
Nonetheless,
back to origin,
Jujitsu camp,
you won't be doing jumping jacks,
pushups 100% unless he wants to you then you can,
you know.
Uh,
but it's more learning,
Jujitsu,
practicing.
Did you too?
No pressure.
Unless you put some pressure on yourself,
which I recommend.
Do that and roll with everybody,
you know.
Do some,
what's the word?
What's the rolling Randori Randori we'll be doing some Randori and some nausea.
Some cut up.
A lot of practice,
by the way.
That's true.
Yeah.
Good.
Let a good install base.
You'll be there.
It will be there.
Dave Burke is going to be the big toe.
He's got the bug.
Yeah.
That's something I haven't talked to JP and or Lafe.
See if they're going to roll up and roll.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
It makes sense,
but yeah.
Nonetheless,
it is August 26 through September 2nd of this year.
Also,
speaking of Boring Jocko
work doing 45 minutes,
the jumping jacks and push ups.
I don't think so,
but if you want to,
interesting.
We're actually,
I shouldn't,
I shouldn't give you,
give you crap about it because I did look on your Instagram and you had like
some Bulgarian bag on there,
so you gotta you vary your workouts.
Your workout gets interesting.
Yeah.
Okay.
I take it credit,
so if you want to make your workout interesting,
gets some new movements,
new equipment in there.
Go to audit.com/jocko/jock.
Go in there,
get you some good kettlebells.
Even though Kettlebells,
I guess ultimately could be viewed as boring.
You can make them boring.
Yeah.
That's kind of boring.
You know what?
Ultimately that's really what it is because even me doing the same metcon that I
do all the time,
all I did was switch up like one teeny tiny thing,
so it was more about me than the workout or it was a workout,
but about the equipment,
less about the equipment,
more about me.
Nonetheless,
if you want to make it about the equipment on it has the equipment may says
steel bells.
See I haven't even done that.
That's like some advanced creativity stuff,
you know,
battle ropes,
all this stuff that'll get you functional strength and actual strength.
Just jokin boner.
That's it.
Anyway on it.com/jacket good spot.
Let a good info on there as well.
Also,
when you get this book called mind over muscle,
I'm going to list it or can you get it on Amazon?
Yep.
Okay.
I'm going to listen on the website talk dot stock come down to me through the
ancient traditional route,
whatever you had a book before that wasn't available and they look kind of like
that.
One of these old school old style books.
Nonetheless,
not this one.
When you get it,
don't worry.
Go to Jocko podcast.com I'll put it in the book section with all the books.
Boom.
Click through there.
Good way to support and you get the book.
Boom.
Also,
if you're doing other shopping,
good.
Continue doing that.
Get the leaf blower.
It's about to be actually is going to be summer before fall,
Huh?
So,
so maybe get a weed whacker,
weed whacker,
some sunscreen,
some surf shorts.
Yeah,
get,
get all that stuff.
It's a good way to spark and support yourself.
Also,
subscribe to the podcast if you haven't already.
Itunes,
stitcher,
Google play,
whatever your preferred podcast listening device slash application is
subscribed.
Good way to support.
Also,
if you want to leave your review,
don't hesitate on that one.
Do what Kaino says.
Make a decision about leaving a review.
Make a decision and just go.
Don't hesitate on the review.
Just do it.
Leave it like everything in life.
You know,
reviews.
No different.
Also on Youtube,
subscribe to our Youtube Channel if you want.
If you care even a little bit about the video version of this podcast and with
chocolate looks like an,
I don't care if you care about what I look like,
but again,
and I still get this by the way,
I guess apparently I don't look how I sound.
Is there like can you match up a voice to a face?
You kind of can't,
Huh?
Yeah.
Like you for sure.
But it's not like a one to one.
It's kind of like,
uh,
like you hear the voice and then there's this ambiguous kind of group of faces
that might go with it.
You know,
it's one of those deals.
It's not just one face comes to mind and that's Kinda,
it's not that,
but it's like,
I guess my face falls way outside of the group of faces that practically
practically,
but that,
that seed normally probably match my voice.
I guess.
That's what I hear too.
Apparently I still hear it.
So if you care,
subscribe to the Youtube Channel or I guess technically you wouldn't have to
subscribe to it.
You just look at it.
But if you want to support at the same time,
if you want subscribe to the podcast on Youtube.
Also have excerpts on that,
so that's another reason.
By the way,
you know you want to share these shorter excerpts with people have watched them,
boom.
Youtube is the place to do it.
Also,
some enhanced excerpts that some calling him today enhance.
Put some music on there,
make you feel good about it.
Here's the thing,
you advocate discipline like the way you feel doesn't matter.
I would say this,
it matters less than discipline.
It still does matter when you're fired up to go do a workout,
when you're fired up to go do a workout versus a day when you really don't want
to do a work
guys,
it then all the time people are like,
oh,
I didn't want to work out today,
but I did anyways and I set a PR in my whatever.
Yeah.
Why does that happen?
That happens sometimes.
No,
no,
no.
Look it up.
Get Out.
The one that it wasn't done with the theory.
If you feel like working out and you're fired up to go work out,
that's going to be a good workout.
Chances are not all the time I get it.
If you really don't feel like working out,
you're dragging ass dragging.
You got 5.5 hours of sleep and you're not Jocko by the way,
and you're,
you ate some snickers or something like this and you're like,
Dang,
I still got to work out.
You really don't feel like an end.
You have a bunch of other stuff to do and you go work out would say about
snickerdoodle.
No,
I mean I know what us,
no,
no.
Is this guy in the teams whose name happened to be nick?
Sure,
and we were in like new guys and we went on a compass course.
The only food that he brought out in the field was,
was snickers like you know like the 12 pack of snickers.
Sure.
Yeah.
I assume.
He brought,
he bought like three 12 packs of stickers and though that's all he brought for
five days.
It didn't go down well,
no,
I wouldn't think so.
He got a mega diarrhea cases,
so the whole marketing,
his nickname was snickerdoodle after that snicker doodle stay pretty funny.
Pretty bummed out.
Actually after that one.
It's good that we had a guy named snickers on our football team at Uah snickers.
He was like that.
He's the center.
Oh,
that was his last name.
No,
it was his nickname on,
but
I did.
That's how you know how certain guys have,
their nickname is so strong you don't like you.
It was like that.
Nonetheless,
back to the point,
if you're fired up to go work out,
chances are you going to have a better workout.
Same thing with the jock was message.
If you're fired up to listen to it,
it might sink in better.
Might you put some good music on it?
Boom.
Might see get better.
It might,
I don't know why it's enhanced,
you know,
special messages.
Nonetheless.
The point there is subscribe to the Youtube Channel if you want.
Good way to support.
Also,
Jocko was a store.
It's called Jocko store.
Jocko.
store.com patches are in because it's been hitting me up.
I haven't seen beanies on there.
Yeah.
You know it's a process.
Well,
here's the thing.
I got to July,
so we've got that going for us.
Yeah.
You know what?
I'm just a job.
Hey man,
you know better late than never.
I guess with those in the meantime is and apply when it's summertime and you're
going to beat it does not apply.
Well maybe I'll get the thin ones.
The straight may do it for a little bit better about it.
No doubt about it.
They look,
you're right and we're still going to work hard on the beanies and get them,
get them out quality.
Can't rush.
Great greatness.
Quality Dude.
You know what,
a nine months for me,
not about Russia could have come with you with all kinds of quality,
like mega quality.
Those things could have been admitted from cash
grown.
The cocktail on the phone.
Right.
All right,
well I'm going to continue to work and you know when they're out,
they're going to be out there going to be fantastic.
They better be right.
There you go.
In the meantime,
maybe it takes a lot to get to a soul into a BB.
Yup.
It could be dot.
It would be in the meantime.
There's some cool shirts on there.
I think they're cool.
Does winning equals freedom?
Get after it?
That's a good one.
Simple to the point.
Back to the book.
That's a new one.
I think you put on another titles.
All of them on the back.
Well,
yeah,
all the book titles up until the point until what?
Podcasts.
I should figure that out.
That's like a layer.
Well,
she'll be the first hundred but you probably didn't do that I think.
No,
no,
no.
It was like hundred something right here.
It's been missed.
That's fine because then we can put it on another back to the book at 200 yeah,
like the updated list.
Vista Layer.
Yeah.
Maybe.
Maybe not.
Or maybe I'll add a layer because layers are Annabelle edible.
Maybe you can add layers.
You see what I'm saying?
Anyway,
so I'm sure it's on there.
Some rash guards on there,
some patches there.
Like I said,
some women's stuff on their hoodies.
Also decals,
you know,
a decal is Jesse's decals.
Jesse's decal.
Here's the thing with decals where they're,
they're essentially a sticker,
right?
And we all know when he comes,
I,
and I understand,
but he uses like this stuff like the material for this decal is like supposed to
survive the apocalypse.
No decals.
Okay.
Yeah.
Good way to support us.
He didn't play around?
No,
not at all.
And this guy like he was getting it all.
We go back and forth and he's like,
yeah,
I make decals.
I was like,
yeah,
that's a good idea.
Whatever.
And then another company called,
I think it was called echelon front,
something like this.
They got some decals and I was like Dang these decals and obviously prompted me
to,
okay,
we need our decals.
They're legit,
they are legit.
And they're on Jocko store.com chipped away.
Good way to support.
If you want something,
get something.
Also psychological warfare,
if you don't know what that is,
this is what it is.
It's an album with tracks of Jocko helping you through.
This is what the track is.
It's,
it's not a music track.
Jocko on there,
every track helping you get through your moment of weakness.
And we have them,
I have Jocko has him even though he,
you know,
is reluctant to admit that from time to time.
And what it does is let's say you're gonna skip the workout.
I think skipping work out,
this is my opinion,
just keep work,
workout and cheat,
not cheating on a diet.
Can you cheat on a diet?
Technically yes.
Yeah.
It's like you're cheating.
You are cheating yourself.
You did it anyway.
You betrayed your,
your yourself.
You know,
cause you have a future self seem saying like your self of right now we'll make
like a a protocol.
Right.
And then your future self essentially cheats on your
yeah,
I saw some meme of homer Simpson saying like all this guy's future's not looking
good.
He's eating like or whatever.
Yeah,
exactly right.
Yup.
So yeah,
technically it is.
If you're cheating on your past self on the Diet,
don't worry about that.
You start feeling that feeling coming along,
come along and you got to track for that.
You just listened to it and it's in,
it's essentially like chocolate telling you why you shouldn't slip,
why you shouldn't slip down that slippery slope in whatever activity.
Some good ones on there,
procrastination,
all that stuff.
Yeah,
checked out.
Went out.
Good way to support.
Very effective too.
That's all iTunes,
apple music,
no Amazon,
Amazon music,
Google play,
apple,
iTunes,
wherever you can get mp3s.
That's where you can get it.
Also you can get from Amazon,
you can get Jocko white tea.
It tastes really good.
It does have 15 grams of caffeine,
so that's a little micro dose.
That's why I put 15 grams of caffeine inside the discipline because that was the
dose that I like.
It has,
but it's only 15 milligrams so you don't get jittery.
It also has a high level of antioxidants.
That's what the pomegranate does.
That's why it's pomegranate white tea.
And of course in addition to those things,
it is the only white tea that comes,
the guaranteed 8,000 pound deadlift.
So that's good.
You've got that going for you.
Um,
even Jordan Peterson now,
you know I got a text from him and he's up to 8,000 or so cause he was plateaued
at 7,000 pounds.
Is he admitted on a,
he doesn't like to admit his weaknesses either,
but
there was 7,000 pounds,
you know,
pretty,
pretty sad.
But now he's a to 8,000 so good for him.
Oh good.
Yeah.
All it took was a little Jocko white tea also.
We got some books,
I got some books I got to,
I got a book called way of the Warrior Kid.
The principles of being a warrior and really of being a good human being.
And they're in there and they are simple and they're clear enough for a six year
old,
a seven year old and eight year olds and 80 year old to understand them and it
gets better because the story continues in the book way of the warrior kid to
Mark's mission.
Okay.
In this book starts to hit on some other principles in life.
Keeping your emotions under control,
working hard,
being frugal,
saving money,
and also dealing with Nathan James.
Nathan James knew bullied psychological bullying a little bit different.
Mark wants to fight him.
Mark figures have been training Jujitsu.
I'm gonna fight this guy,
but instead,
uncle g uncle Jake says,
no,
you can find him first.
You have to gather intelligence on them.
You have to figure out what's going on with
Nathan James,
understand why he's your enemy and see if there's another way to solve this
problem before besides fighting turns out to be very good.
Also,
mark has a Jujitsu tournament coming up and guess what?
He doesn't want to compete in it.
He doesn't want to do is first Jiu Jitsu tournament.
Why?
Because he's afraid.
He's afraid of losing.
He's afraid of failing.
Fear of failure.
That's bad.
So he's got all these problems.
How did you overcome them?
Well,
luckily uncle Jake's in the house or go,
Jake is out for the summertime,
gives him a hand order.
That book is going to be available.
April 24th same thing with all the other books for the last two books that have
come out.
It's going to sell out.
The publisher doesn't understand how many books to make.
They want to hedge their bets,
so they're just going to make a certain amount.
So the more people order.
Now,
first of all,
you'll get it when it comes out.
And second of all,
they'll know that they need to make more and order it from wherever.
Order it from Amazon,
order it from Barnes,
noble.
But going to your local bookstore,
this is a mission.
Go to your local bookstore and tell them you want the book marks,
mission way,
the warrior kid to tell him,
do you want that?
Okay.
That will help spread the word.
And also while you're helping out warrior kids,
check out Irish oaks ranch.com where you can get soap made by young Aiden who
was only 12 years old.
He's got his own business and the soap isn't just any soap.
It's good.
So then he actually called the Jocko soap and the jock was soap motto that I
made up.
Yup.
Aiden gets no credit for this.
The motto is stay clean and someone said there's a layer in stake.
Lean,
lean,
stay clean layers.
No big deal.
Yeah.
I also don't forget about the discipline equals freedom field manual.
This is the manual for getting after it faults and actions that will keep you
off the slippery slope and to keep you on the path,
the path of discipline and thereby as the title says,
the path of freedom.
If you want the audio version of that,
it's not on audible.
It's an album with tracks.
Discipline equals freedom field manual on iTunes,
Amazon music,
Google play.
That's where you can get it.
And also extreme ownership,
combat leadership broken down into pragmatic strategies and tactics that you can
apply to your business and life.
Boom.
Still on the Amazon bestseller list still on Wall Street Journal,
keeping it real
and if you want or you need to take it to the next level.
Echelon front is my leadership and management consulting company.
The overwhelming factor in the success of any business or team.
His leadership,
that's what it is,
and at Echelon Front we come to your company and train and align your leadership
so that you work effectively together as a team to dominate your battlefield.
It's me,
it's my brother Leif Babin,
JP Denelle,
Dave Burke.
You can email info national on front.com or visit the website echelon front.com
and of course the muster is our leadership seminar or only doing two this year.
Washington DC,
May 17th and 18th in San Francisco.
October 17th 18th the DC musters to third sold out.
Right now the two thirds sold out and it's going to sell out soon.
The SF muster is in October and it's already a third sold out,
so both of them are absolutely going to sell out.
We can't expand the spaces anymore.
We've packed as as many chairs as they're in there as we can in desk.
So you,
we can't fit any more people,
so if you want to come get registered now@extremeownership.com the entire
echelon front team will be there.
All of us including Echo Charles.
And by the way,
there's no green room.
We won't be backstage getting are um,
getting our,
our scalps massage.
No,
we will be out front.
We'll be kicking it with you interacting,
answering questions,
talking,
eating,
working out,
hanging out,
just basically getting after it with you.
So come and get it at the magister at the monster.
Get registered as quick as you can and until we do the muster,
if you have questions or comments or answers or you just want to cruise with us
kind of hard,
then you can find us on the Inter webs on Twitter,
on Instagram and on [inaudible] he she bookie Heco is that Echo Charles and I am
at Jocko Willink and thanks to you all for listening to the podcast,
especially those of you in uniform who took an oath to protect this country and
you stand by that oath literally around the world on the front lines and to the
police and law enforcement and firefighters and paramedics and all the first
responders that are always on call to help us when the chips are down and that
are ready to make that sacrifice like so many did on September 11th thank you
for what you do and let's remember and give thanks to the people every day like
Jeremy Glick who stood up.
Yeah.
Along with the other members of flight 93 they stood up and fought when the time
called for it.
They let us all be prepared to do the same.
To stand up and fight if we need to,
to be prepared to face evil by staying on the path,
by knowing what your principles are and sticking to them.
Be Vigilant.
Pay Attention.
Pay attention to the little things,
the little decisions,
the decisions that pull you off the path and onto that slippery slope with bad
habits that will let you down at the moment of truth.
Okay?
Watch out for those little decisions.
Instead,
stay on the path,
the path of discipline,
the path that leads to security and strength,
and of course to freedom.
And that's the path of getting after it.
So until next time,
this is echo and Jocko
out.